Israël et les 5 jours de conflit
meurtriers dans la région seront au cœur
de cette première séance de question
d'actualité au Gouvernement les
sénateurs sont particulièrement sensible
à cette situation on les a d'ailleurs vu
en nombre lundi soir au rassemblement en
soutien à Israël à Paris des sénateurs
qui prennent donc le sujet à bras le
corp via différents angles d'attaque le
soutien de la France la condamnation de
ces actes par la classe politique et les
répercussions que cela pourrait avoir
que ces événements pourraient avoir ici
en France une dernière information à
vous donner Tam cette séance elle va
s'ouvrir avec deux hommages un premier
pour les victimes de ces derniers jours
en Israël à travers des prises de parole
de Gérard Larcher et d'Élizabeth B mais
également un deuxème hommage pour
l'ancienne sénatrice socialiste de
Guadeloupe victoire jasmin qui nous a
quitté vendredi dernier à l'âge de 67
ans tamame merci beaucoup Mathias tandis
que l'on voit Gérard larchi le président
du Sénat qui s'installe au plateau et le
président du Sénat qui vous le disiez va
faire d'abord une déclaration solennelle
à l'occasion de l'ouverture de cette
séance de question au gouvernement
hommage solanel aux victimes après
l'attaque d'Israël l'attaque terroriste
d'Israël parle Hamas samedi on l'écoute
la séance est
ouverte le contendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribué nous
n'avons pas reçu
d'observation il y en a-t-il en
séance je n'en vois point le
procèsverbal est donc adopté sous les
réserves
d'usage madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les
ministres Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
d'Israël mes chers
collègues le 7 octobre au
matin le Hamas a déclenché une opération
terroriste de grande ampleur sur le sol
israélien seement la désolation et la
mort engendra un climat de terreur qui
n' dégale que la cruauté dont les
terroristes Islamist du Hamas ont fait
preuve à l'égard des
victimes pour Israël et les démocraties
allons pas douter il y aura un avant et
un après le 7 octobre
2023 comme il y eu un avant et un après
le 11 septembre 2001 et un avant et un
après cette terrible année 2015 dans
notre pays la France
rappelons-nous pour nous
Français le massacre du Bataclan trouve
un écho
singulier dans le massacre de jeunes
israéliens que la musique av avait
réuni
rappelons-nous les rues de Paris
parcourues par les terroristes
s'apparent étrangement aux rues et
routes des villes et de certains
kibuts aujourd'hui dans un deuil
profond
rappelons-nous partout des assassinats
des
otages et l'odieux chantage qui pèse sur
leur
vie mais en Israël
c'est toute une armée terroriste qui a
déferlé puissante organisée soutenue par
des pays
étrangers donnant à cette attaque une
ampleur inédite les massaces commis dans
les kibout de Berry et far hasard on un
nom des crimes contre
l'humanité
rappelons-nous l'État d'Israël était au
premier rang en 2015 au premier ant des
soutiens apportés à la France le
président de la cissette m'avait alors
écrit je cite sa lettre la France blessé
fait saigner le cœur
d'Israël puisse la France aujourd'hui
être la plus
fervante au côté des
Israéliens en cet
instant il convient de penser aux
victimes israéliennes et à celles
d'autres nationalités notamment à nos
compatriotes à leurs familles à leurs
proches à ceux qui aujourd'hui encore
sont portés disparu ou qui enlevé ont
été violentés et pris en otage nous
exigeons la libération immédiate et sans
condition de tous les
otages ceux qui les détiennent seront
tenu responsable de leur
vie j'ai exprimé en votre nom à tous oui
à tous mes chers collègues la solidarité
du Sénat en écrivant au président de
l'État d'Israël monsieur Herzog et au
président de la
cnaissette notre collègue
Oana mais je souhaiterais que d'un seul
mouvement nous puissions
ensemble manifester notre détermination
à nous tenir auprès du peuple d'Israël
peuple MEUR
traumatisé affaibli peut-être mais
valeureux portant haut des valeurs qui
sont les nôtres celles de la démocratie
parlementaire et de la liberté un pleup
en un mot
inébrolllable je vous
invite à vous lever pour observer une
minute de silence vous étiez debout mais
je voulais vous le redire parce que il y
a un moment où nous devons nous élever
tous
ensemble
donner la parole à madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur d'Israël mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
alors que des attaques terroristes
effroyables ont touché l'État
d'Israël je veux au nom de mon
gouvernement dire toute ma solidarité et
mon soutien au peuple
israélien chaque jour nous découvrons de
nouvelles horreurs commises par les
terroristes du
Hamas chaque jour le bilan s'alourdit et
je veux redire solennellement avant
toute chose que rien jamais
ne peut justifier le
terrorisme aujourd'hui je pense aux
victimes et j'exprime la compassion de
la France à leur famille et à leurs
proches alors que le bilan vient une
nouvelle fois de
s'alourdir je veux avoir un mot
particulier pour nos 10 ressortissants
décédés et les 18 dont nous sommes sans
nouvelles dans ce moment tragique je
sais l'émotion et l'angoisse qui
saisissent les Français vivants en
Israël et les
franco-israéliens nous sommes avec eux
et nos services diplomatiques mettent
tout en œuvre pour les
accompagner mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs le président de la République
l'a dit avec force nous sommes au côté
d'Israël pays allié de la France qui vit
un drame terrible je vous
remercie merci madame la Première
ministre chers collègues je vous invite
à vous
lever mes chers collègues l'émotion qui
a suivi la disparition brutale de
victoire jasmin montre l'estime dont
elle bénéficiait tant dans notre
assemblée qu'en
Guadeloupe c'est en 2008 que sa carrière
politique débute avec son élection au
conseil municipal de mornalo dont elle
dev un premier adjoin au maire
elle est réélue en
2014 puis en
2020 2017
elle est élue sénatrice de la Guadeloupe
au sein de notre haute assemblée elle
intègre le groupe socialiste écologiste
et républicain son groupe et tout
naturellement la commission des affaires
sociales la conviction la générosité et
l'engagement avec lesquel elle exerce
son mandat de sénatrice sont à la
hauteur de la conception exigeante
qu'elle a de sa mission en faveur de son
territoire et de ceux qui
l'habit femme de terrain chaleureuse
enthousiaste
elle demeure constamment à l'écoute de
ses concitoyens femme de combat
résolument de gauche elle inscrit son
action autour des principes de la
République la liberté l'égalité la
fraternité femme de dossier les
scrupuleuse et déterminé animé par un
idéal de justice apprécié reconnu par
ses collègues ces travaux firent honneur
à notre assemblée je pense en
particulier au rapport sur les risques
naturels majeurs dans les outr mers ou
sur la parentalité dans les outr mers
rapport récent dont elle était
co-auteur
elle savait concilier vie familiale vie
associative vie politique vie
professionnelle de multiples entre
guillemets casquettes qui l'incite à
lutter en faveur de la valorisation de
la femme dans une société plus
égalitaire victoire jasmin intervient
également sur de nombreux texte
législatif déposera au cours de son
mandat beaucoup d'amendements dans
certains comme celui de la prise en
charge des tests clordcon sur les
humains un véritable sujet aux ltillle
ont été adopté à l'unanimité je le
rappelle par le Sénat enfin j'ai pu
mesurer lors des réunions du Bureau du
Sénat où elle était secrétaire du Sénat
l'énergie déployée en sa qualité de
secrétaire pour assumer ses
responsabilités en particulier au côté
de notre collègue Pascal gruni lors de
la réflexion menée pour renforcer le
contrôle parlementaire
au
moment son corps va être
transporté vers sa terre natale son île
à laquelle elle était tant attachée je
voulais que au nom du Sénat tout entier
nous assurions de notre profonde
sympathie n nous les avons rencontré
hier soir ses enfants sa petite fille
l'ensemble de la famille et ses proches
et je vous propose de partager je la
vois encore ici dans cette hémicycle là
en face je vous propose de partager un
moment de souvenir et de
recueillement
merci notre ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement je
vous rappelle que notre séance est
retransmise en direct sur Public Sénat
et sur notre
site chacun d'entre vous mes chers
collègues sera attentif au cours de nos
échanges
à respecter l'une des valeurs essentiel
du Sénat le respect qu'il s'agisse du
respect des uns et des autres mais aussi
plus prosaïquement c'est essentiel le
respect du temps de
parole je vais donner la parole au
président Patrick canner pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
monsieur le
président
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre merci au président Larcher tout
d'abord pour ces paroles de
solidarité nous avons le cœur brisé pour
les victimes et leurs familles et une
pensée particulière pour nos
compatriotes qui ont perdu la vie ou qui
ont été pris en otage nous n'avons plus
de mots et pourtant tout est dit tout
est dit dans l'article 15 de la Charte
du ramas je cite face à l'usurpation de
la Palestine par les Juifs il faut
brandir l'étandard du djihad les scènes
insoutenable dans les kibutsim de faraza
et de Berry raisonneront à jamais dans
la mémoire du peuple israélien comme
pour nous les morts de Charlie de
l'hypercacher du Bataclan ou de la
Promenade des Anglais rafle porome choix
par balle décapitation au couteau de
femmes et d'enfants relève sans nul
doute d' une volonté
génocidaire alors oui comme daesh le
Hezbolah le Djihad islamique ou Boko
Haram le ramasse est bien une
organisation terroriste une filiale de
la
mort ne pas ne pas clairement le
reconnaître sous couvert d'explications
vaseuses rel de
l'indignité alors
oui alors oui comme n'importe que
n'importe quel autre État de droit
Israël a le droit de se défendre il doit
le faire dans le respect des conventions
internationales alors oui le Sénat le
Sénat le Hamas excusez-moi monsieur le
Président alors oui le
ramas la terreur et leur ramasse à
horreur de nos valeurs démocratie
liberté d'expression laïcité droit des
femmes à disposer d'elles-même ce
prosélitisme de l'obscurantisme qui
touche de manière protéiforme toute la
planète doit être dénoncé et combattu
l'Union européenne est-elle vraiment au
niveau pour relever le défi alors oui le
ramas combat toutes ses forces de toutes
ses forces toute idée de paix symbolisé
aujourd'hui par les accords d'Abraham il
faut aider le peuple palestinien de Gaza
à se libérer des tyrans qui le poussent
dans une impasse mortifère les
progressistes des deux peuples doivent
être encouragés accompagnés défendus
deux états pour une paix durable il faut
retrouver l'esprit des accords d'Oslo
madame la Première ministre vous avez
indiqué à l'Assemblée nationale que la
France tiendrait toute sa place et
ferait tout pour trouver une solution
politique quelles sont les initiatives
précises que vous comptez engager mes
chers collègues soutenir le peuple
israélien aujourd'hui dans le drame
indiciible qu'il subit c'est défendre
une certaine idée de
l'humanité
merci merci monsieur le
président madame la Première ministre
pour vous
répondre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs les
sénateurs monsieur le présid ident
P tout d'abord je veux à mon tour rendre
hommage à la sénatrice victoire jasmin
disparue la semaine dernière par ses
combats et ses engagements c'était une
figure forte et respectée de notre vie
politique en Guadeloupe comme au Sénat
au nom du gouvernement je tenais à lui
rendre
hommage vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président samedi dernier l'horreur du
terrorisme a frappé Israël depuis samedi
chaque jour de nouvelles monstruosités
commises par les terroristes du Hamas et
du Djihad islamique sont découvertes et
au tir de roquettes aux enlèvements y
compris de personnes âgées et d'enfants
se sont ajouté une série de massacres
lors d'un festival à l'est de Gaza ou
dans les kibuts de Berry et de karaza et
vous avez dit monsieur le Président
combien ces drames font écho à d'autres
drames survenu sur le territoire
national
l'horreur c'est le seul mot qui convient
pour décrire ces attaques terroriste et
notre soutien doit être total au nom du
gouvernement je veux dire à nouveau
toute ma solidarité envers le peuple
israélien envers les victimes leurs
familles et leurs proches je veux avoir
une pensée particulière pour les
victimes françaises et pour nos
compatriotes disparus dont la situation
est ex
préoccupante parmi eux plusieurs enfants
probablement enlevés nous sommes en lien
constant avec les famille je veux
adresser toutes mes pensées à la
Communauté française en Israël qui vit
dans l'angoisse le Centre de Crise du
quai d'orsé et notre ambassade sont
pleinement mobilisés pour les
accompagner par ailleurs nous
travaillons activement au côté
d'ir-france pour que des solutions de
retour soient proposées à tous nos
ressortissants qui le souhaite un vol
spécial a d'ors et déjà été confirmé
demain et nous travaillons à différentes
options jusqu'à la reprise des vols
régulier nous soutenons Israël dans
cette épreuve et comme l'a fait le
président de la République je le dis
sans
ambigué face au terrorisme Israël a le
droit de se défendre face à la barbarie
personne ne peut remettre en cause ce
droit je veux aussi dire aux Juifs de
France choqués par cette attaque et
inquiet par ses répercussions sur notre
sol national que nous sommes à leur côté
l'antisémitisme n'a pas sa place en
France l'antisémitisme n'a pas sa place
dans la République l'antisémitisme est
un délit nous ne laisseront rien passer
le ministre de l'Intérieur a
immédiatement passé des consignes de
vigilance aux forces de l'ordre et au
préfet afin notamment de renforcer la
protection des lieux les plus
sensibles monsieur le Président canner
la France n'oublie pas son histoire et
sa responsabilité pour la paix nous
devons tout faire pour éviter
l'embrasement de la région permettre la
désescalade la protection des civils et
le respect du droit international c'est
le sens des échanges constants que mène
le président de la République et la
ministre des Affaires étrangères avec
leurs homologues depuis les
attaques monsieur le Président canner
dans un tel
nous avons le devoir collectivement de
faire vivre les valeurs de la République
et de défendre la cohésion
nationale je me réjouis de voir que dans
cette assemblée cette conviction est
partagée par toutes et tous sans
exception je vous
remercie merci madame la Première
ministre je vais donner la parole à
notre collègue Robert
R pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen écologéiste kanaki chers
collègues vous avez la parole pour la
première fois je crois dans cet
hémicycle merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Intérieur et des autres mères c'est la
première fois que je m'exprime devant
cette assemblée je voudrais le faire
avec respect et humilité avec le peuple
français que vous représentez le peuple
canak n'est pas l'ennemi du peuple
français il veut mettre fin à une
histoire coloniale de 70 ans le
gouvernement a remis le 6 septembre 2023
un document présenté comme un projet
d'accord et qui aurait vocation à être
le support d'une révision de la
Constitution ce texte commence par dire
que le peuple calédonien a manifesté sa
volonté que la Nouvelle-Calédonie reste
dans la France je rappelle qu'au 3e
référendum 56 % des Calédoniens se sont
abstenus dans plus de 80 90 % de canak
le peuple peuple calédonien sans le
peuple Canac n'existe pas disait
l'historien calédonien José barbasson ce
résultat est contesté devant l' que dit
ce document d'abord il abandonne toute
trajectoire de décolonisation le
référendum envisagé vise à refaire
accepter un statut d'autonomie dans la
France prétexte à la désinscription de
notre pays de la liste des territoire
décolonisé il vise ensuite à se
substituer à l'accord de Na en lui
faisant perd sa valeur constitutionnelle
il veut enfin ouvrir le périmètre du
peuple calédonien aux arrivants ayant 10
ans de résidence un corord électoral
glissant légitime la colonie du
peuplement ce qui est contraire aux
résolutions de l'un aux équilibres
négociés en 98 le manque d'impartialité
amène aujourd'hui un débat stérile il
est nécessaire que l'État puisse
comprendre que le temps du palable est
un temps de sagesse monsieur le ministre
ma question est la suiv suivante sans
consensus le gouvernement compte-il
contre l' viis du fllnkss et comme au 3è
référendum passer en force cette
révision constitutionnelle où
envisage-t-il de présenter lors de
bilatéral de décolonisation un nouveau
document qui se situerait enfin dans la
continuité historique de l'accord de nè
merci pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur
rou que je cherche pardon
voilà à nouveau la Nouvelle-Calédonie
est à un moment important de son
histoire il s'agit à l'issue du
processus politique prévu par l'accord
de numea de dessiner son avenir
institutionnel au cours des derniers
mois le président de la République et le
gouvernement se sont employés à créer
les conditions d'un dialogue serein et
constructif avec les indépendantistes et
les non
indépendantistes lors de sa visite en
Nouvelle-Calédonie fin juillet dernier
le président de la République a proposé
à chacun le pacte de numea autour de
deux chemins le pardon et
l'avenir sur cette base il a invité les
acteurs politiques à travailler à la
recherche de consensus sur chaque
sujet début septembre une semaine de
discussion s'est tenu à Paris à mon
invitation j'ai réuni l'ensemble des
acteurs à Matignon le ministre de
l'Intérieur et des outremèes a organisé
plusieurs réunions avec les
délégations la conclusion de cette
discussion autour du président de la
République et avec toutes les parties a
permis de faire le bilan de ces échanges
et de tracer les perspectives
perspectives pour la recherche d'un
accord dans les tous prochains mois et
au terme de ces échanges tous non
indépendantistes comme indépendantiste
se sont engagés à poursuivre les
discussions sur la base d'un projet
d'accord que le ministre de l'Intérieur
et des outremires Gérald armanin vient
de transmettre au parti ce document est
une base de travail il appartient au
partis de formuler leurs propositions
concrètes le gouvernement souhaite
parvenir à un accord d'ici la fin de
l'année ceci suppose néanmoins que tous
participent aux discussions animées par
la volonté d'aboutir
le ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outremaires se rendra à nouveau en
Nouvelle-Calédonie fin octobre le moment
venu le gouvernement proposera
présentera un projet de révision
constitutionnelle pour tirer les
conséquences de l'accord trouvé cette
révision devra notamment permettre le
dégel du corps électoral des élections
provinciales qui est une exigence
démocratique comme l'Accord de numea en
1998 le projet d'accord sera soumis à
l'approbation de la population
calédonienne et une fois l'accord entré
en vigueur les élections provinciales
seront organisées il s'agit de pouvoir
organiser ce rendez-vous démocratique il
s'agit aussi d'avancer et comme l'a dit
le président de la République nous
n'avons pas le droit d'attendre c'est
l'avenir que nous sommes en train de
construire celui de la jeunesse
calédonienne celui de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie dans la République je
vous
remercie merci la parole est
maintenant au président Hervé Marseille
pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste monsieur le Président Madame
la première ministre mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues à mon
tour au nom de mon groupe je voudrais
m'associer au président l'archer dans
ses propos vis-à-vis d'Israël et nous
tenons bien sûr au côté d'Israël dans
cette épreuve notre continent notre
vieux continent depuis des siècles a
connu bien des guerres des massacres des
prommes des charniers des horreurs de
toutes sortes nous pensions avoir
atteint le bout de ces horreurs dans ce
que nous avons entendu et vu et puis
finalement un degré supplémentaire a été
perpétré en Israël le 7 octobre avec
l'incursion des tueurs du Hamas des
hommes des femmes des vieillards des
bébés
décapités on navait jamais vu ça
c'est un avilissement cela a été dit par
le président canner de la civilisation
l'humanité c'est insupportable on ne
trouve plus les mots j'ai cherché
moi-même les mots que je pouvais
employer on ne trouve plus les mots
c'est tueur parce que certains
voudraient nous faire croire qu'il
s'agit de résistants on n jamais vu des
résistants qui tuaient des enfants des
jeunes des jeunes hommes et des jeunes
femmes dans une rêveptie ou qui
décapitent des bébé on n jamais vu ça
sont des tueurs tout simplement et ces
tueurs ils sortent pas nulle part part
ils ont été accompagnés ils ont été
aidés entraînés financés et on sait par
qui on sait par qui par le Qatar puisque
le chef des tueurs est hébergé au Qatar
monsieur anier est au Qatar cela même
qui finance ici le PSG ou d'autres
grandes
entreprises et
puis et puis il y a l'Iran et nous avons
été très conciliant vis-à-vis de l'Iran
dans le dossier nucléaire en particulier
pour rechercher des solutions parce que
nous pensions que c'était important pour
la paix dans le monde et pour la région
alors madame la Première ministre ma
question est simple quelles conséquences
le gouvernement tire-t-il de
l'implication de ces deux pays dans les
relations avec ces pays et quelles
actions entendons-nous prendre en France
pour mettre un terme à leur implication
dans ces meurtres barbares je vous
remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Madame la premiè
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le président Hervé
Marseille l'attaque terroriste commise
par le Hamas contre Israël est odieuse
vous l'avez dit
inqualifiable un groupe terroriste sen
est pris à des civils dans un de
roquettes de violence dans une
multiplication ignoble d'actes de
barbarie des femmes des hommes des
personnes âgées des jeunes et des
enfants parfois même des bébés ont été
pris pour cible et comme toutes les
démocraties nous sommes au côté d'Israël
dans ces moments
terribles vous m'interrogez sur le rôle
de certains États dans cette
action d'abord avec l'ensemble de la
communauté
internationale nous appelons tous les
États à a condamné ces actes terroristes
aucun gouvernement ne peut rester
insensible face à ces
images s'agissant de l'Iran en
particulier le président de la
République a eu l'occasion de s'exprimer
hier nous n'avons pas de preuve formelle
de l'implication de l'Iran nous
consolidons nos analyses avec nos
partenaires ce qui est clair c'est le
caractère inacceptable des images de
triomphalisme ou de certains propos des
autorités iranienne il n'y a aucune
ambigué possible je condamne comme vous
avec la plus grande fermeté les pays qui
se sont félicités de cette attaque
terroriste
monstrueuse face à la gravité de la
situation nous agissons et nous agirons
en
responsabilité nous soutenons le droit
d'Israël à se défendre contre le
terrorisme sous l'égite du président de
la République la diplomatie est à
l'œuvre pour éviter l'embrasement et
l'escalade dans la région nous sommes en
contact étroit avec nos partenaires pour
que la communauté internationale fasse
la lumière sur ces événement et le rôle
des uns et des autres nous rappelons que
les civils doivent être protégés et le
droit international respecté nous
soutenons toujours une solution
politique au conflit israélo-palestinien
notre position n'a pas changé nous
agissons également avec nos partenaires
européens la coordination entre les
États-membres doit être entière et et
hier s'est tenue une réunion informelle
des 27 ministres des Affaires étrangères
de l'Union européenne monsieur le
Président Marseille nous sommes au côté
du peuple israélien et avec nos
partenaires nous travaillons à
identifier toutes les responsabilités
dans cette attaque inacceptable je vous
remercie la parole est maintenant au
président Gontard pour le groupe
écologie solidarité et
territoire merci merci monsieur le
président ident madame la Première
ministre depuis samedi nos cœurs sont
étreints par l'attaque terroriste
injustifiable et sans précédent opéré
par le Hamas sur le territoire d'Israël
nous condamnons avec la plus grande
fermeté la barbarie qui s'est déchaîné
contre les populations civiles oui
effectivement il n'y a pas de mot aux
victimes de ces actes abjects aux étages
détenus à Gaza dont nous demandons la
libération à leurs familles leurs
proches au peuple d'Israël à son
ambassadeur et à ses amis à travers le
monde nous témoignons notre profonde
émotion et notre
solidarité nous déplorons avec la même
émotion le nouveau cycle de violence
aveugle qui s vit au Proche Orient et
qui a déjà fait plusieurs milliers de
victimes israéliennes et palestiniennes
du jamais vu depuis la guerre du Kipour
nous craignons l'embrasement de toute la
région nous portons la conviction qu'une
nouvelle guerre contre la terreur ne
renforcera en aucune façon la sécurité
d'Israël à laquelle nous sommes
profondément attachés depuis 65 ans la
violence ne résout rien il est impératif
d'en sortir au plus vite pour cela le
blocus de Gaza dont l'ONU vient rappeler
l'illégalité doit être levé et l'aide
humanitaire préservée les palestiniennes
et les Palestiniens ne peuvent plus être
désumanisé comme l'a fait le ministre
israélien de la Défense l'an dernier je
me suis rendu à Gaza en Cis-Jordanie et
en Israël avec une délégation de la
commission des affaires étrangères nous
déplorions déjà l'inaction de la France
de l'Union européenne et de la
communauté internationale nous y
formulions plusieurs propositions pour
bâtir une paix durable entre les peuples
seul à même de préserver la sécurité
d'Israël paix durable qui passera
nécessairement par le strict respect du
droit international et l'abandon de la
colonisation madame la Première ministre
pour participer à la construction d'une
solution diplomatique pour permettre un
cesser le feu et la paix la France doit
garder comme boussole absolue le respect
du droit international alors madame la
Première ministre quelle sera votre
politique
merci madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénateur
monsieur le Président Guillaume
Gontard aujourd'hui face aux attaques
terroristes mené par le Hamas et le
Djihad islamique Israël traverse un
drame épouvantable et notre solidarité
envers le peuple israélien est total
face à une attaque d'une telle ampleur
et une telle horreur Israël a le droit
de se défendre personne ne peut le
contester c'est la position de toutes
les démocraties c'est la conviction de
la France car nous soutiendrons toujours
la liberté et la lutte contre le
terrorisme éidemment dans un tel
contexte la France est extrêmement
active et vigilante pour veiller à la
désescalade éviter l'embrasement de la
région s'assurer de la protection des
civils et du respect du droit
international ces derniers jours le
président de la République a multiplié
les contacts avec nos partenaires dans
la région la ministre des Affaires
étrangères a fait de même avec ses
homologues chacun doit mesurer les
risques de la situation
monsieur le Président Gontard la France
a toujours défendu et cherché le chemin
de la paix nous restons fidèles à cet
engagement historique le Hamas ne veut
pas la paix c'est un groupe terroriste
antisémite meurtrier dont le seul but
est d'anéantir l'État d'Israël nous
détourner du processus de paix ce serait
donneré une victoire aux terroristes
notre position n'a pas varié la France
recherchera toujours une paix durable et
une solution politique dans le conflit
israélo-palestinien nous n'y sommes pas
le chemin sera long mais rien ne doit
nous détourner de cette ambition c'est
la seule qui permettra la stabilité et
la sécurité dans la région je vous
remercie la parole est au président
kucci pour le groupe les
républicains madame la Première ministre
mal nommé les choses c'est ajouté au
malheur du monde disait Albert
Camu nous sommes la France héritière des
philosophes de la Révolution française
et de la Déclaration des Droits de
l'Homme du Conseil National de la
Résistance de Léon Blom et du général de
GA nous sommes le pays porteur de la
liberté de la tolérance de
l'universalité ça veut dire Madame la
prère ministre que nous avons une
responsabilité imminente nous ne pouvons
pas faire pardon madame la ministre des
Affaires étrangères des déclarations
uniquement type kdoré surfiche ou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas nous sommes là pour dire simplement
l'empathie n'est pas exclusive de
l'action politique nous sommes là pour
vous dire qu'il faut utiliser les mots
crime contre l'humanité c'est la réalité
ce mot cette expression utilisz là
faites-la utiliser par l'E Europe
franchement vu ce qui s'est passé crime
contre l'humanité c'est bien le minimum
la légitime défense de l'État d'Israël
c'est un droit permanent quand vous
recevez des milliers de de missiles et
que vous assistez à ce qui s'est passé
dans les kibut légitime défense c'est le
minimum et faites en sorte madame la
Première ministre que celles et ceux qui
dans la République trahissent les
valeurs de la République trahissent les
valeurs de la nation en ne soutenant pas
l'état d'Israël et en faisant l'apologie
du terrorisme faites en sorte qu'il soit
sévèrement
puni
est à Madame la Ministre de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères madame Colona
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur carucci je ne voudrais pas en
venir à penser que vous n'avez pas bien
entendu le président de la République
Monsieur le Sénateur madame la Première
ministre je n'ai
pas je n'ai pas imaginé que vous fassiez
attention à mes propos madame la
Première ministre vient de rappeler
toute l'horreur que nous inspirent les
actes barbares qui ont été commis par le
Hamas et de dire de redire la
condamnation absolu par la France de ces
actes terroristes commis par un groupe
terroriste le Hamas soutenu par d'autres
groupes terroristes et de plus les
prises d' Tage abjectent les assassinats
monstrueux les massacres ne laisse aucun
doute sur la nature terroriste du Hamas
notre condamnation est donc total et
absolu et ceci depuis le premier jour
Monsieur le Sénateur face à l'horreur
nous sommes solidaires d'Israël et du
peuple israélien et nous disons avec
force qu'Israël a le droit de se
défendre nous l'avons dit publiquement
depuis le premier jour nous le redisons
nous le disons à tous nos interlocuteurs
dans la région et ailleurs et dans le
même temps oui la première ministre le
disait la responsabilité diplomatique de
la France est aussi d'éviter
l'embrasement
dans la région l'Autorité palestinienne
a un rôle à jouer à cet égard nous
continuons la soutenir le président de
la République s'est exprimé sur ce point
très clairement hier la diplomatie
française est aussi active pour que la
situation ne s'aggrave pas à la
frontière avec le Liban je ne doute pas
que vous suiviez avec attention ce qui
s'y passe comme à la frontière avec la
Syrie le président de la République et
moi-même avons multiplié les contacts
depuis samedi avec nos homologues
Israéliens Palestiniens dans la région
européens et bien au-delà et bien sûr
comme l'a dit madame la Première
ministre quand le calme sera revenu il
faudra se demander comment mieux prendre
en compte les aspiration du peuple
palestinien comment mieux répondre au
droit absolu d'Israël à la sécurité la
paix doit rester notre impératif même si
d'évidence ce moment n'est pas
venu monsieur
[Applaudissements]
carucci la parole est au président
François patria pour le Grou du
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et
indépendants monsieur le Président
Madame la première ministre mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues l'heure est à la gravité
l'heure est au recueillement l'heure est
à l'unité d'heure en heure depuis samedi
l'orure monte à son comble vous êtes
plusieurs monsieur le Président la
première ministre vous mes chers
collègues avoir dit votre colère et
votre
émotion aujourhui nous la partageons
tous tous les témoignages qui nous
parviennent de l'attaque terroriste
perpétré par le Hamas contre les civils
israéliens mais aussi étrangers nous
bouleverse et nous révolte tous des
spectacles de carnage des sommets de
l'horreur ont été atteints des femmes
violées puis exécutées des hommes
décapités des cadavres souillés et
calcinés des enfants victimes innocentes
de cette folie barbare cette folie elle
raisonne durement pour nous qui avons
connu le terrorisme islamiste elle nous
rappelle daesh Al-Qaïda Boko Haram vous
l'avez dit monsieur le Président aussi
au peuple israélien nous affirmons auut
effort notre solidarité s'ans faille une
fois encore ce sont les civils qui en
payent le prix fort j'ai une pensée
toute particulière pour nos compatriotes
qui ont perdu dans ce drame pour les
otages français don nous espérons le
retour et bien sûr à leur famillees je
pense aussi à nos concitoyens établis
sur place à cet égard nous souhaitons
vivement remercier notre personnel
diplomatique et consulaire qui a
pleinement mobilisé dans cette crise je
pense également aux Palestiniens pris en
otage par le Hamas qui s'enerbe de
boucliers humain et qui pont le prix du
sang à la place des lâches qui tirent
sur des femmes des enfants et des hommes
sans défense à ceux qui soutenant le
Hamas et pensent soutenir les
Palestiniens nous disons que cet
aveuglement idéologique ne fait
qu'ajouter à leurs malheur le monde
s'embrase les foyers de guerre se
multiplient et alors que nos yeux sont
tournés vers l'Ukraine le haut carabac
voici un douloureux rappel de
l'instabilité du Proche Orient 30 ans
après la signature des Accords d'Oslo le
Hamas a décidé de réveiller les démons
de la guerre ces démons en d'Europe
aussi nous les connaissons ils sont
aveugles dans la violence et sourds aux
appels à la paix moiussi madame la
Première ministre aujourd'hui comment la
France pays amis le médiateur d'un
dialogue pour la paix peut-elle uvrer
pour que l'espoir né des accords
d'Abraham continue de vivre et pour
empêcher la radicalisation des peuples
face aux menaces je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est à madame la Première ministre merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président François
patria après les attaques terroristes
effroyables mené contre Israël par le
Hamas et le Djihad islamique la France a
immédiatement exprimé sa compassion et
sa solidarité avec le peuple israélien
et condamner fermement ses
agressions nous l'av avons dit et je le
répète face aux
terroristes face à une telle attaque une
attaque aussi barbare Israël a le droit
de se
défendre dans cette situation la France
tient sa place et nous sommes
particulièrement actif pour éviter que
le conflit ne dégénère par un
embrasement en Cisjordanie au Liban ou
dans la région le président de la
République s'est entretenu avec de
nombreux homologues parmi lesquels le
président israélien Isaac Herzog et le
Premier ministre Benjamin netanahou le
président de l'Autorité palestinienne
mmoud Abbas le président égyptien Sissi
le président du Conseil libanais Najib
Mikati le président émirien Mohamed Ben
Zayed le roi Abdallah de Jordanie et il
a eu des échanges avec le prince
héritier saoudien Mohamed Ben Salman
nous allons poursuivre ces contacts et
nous travaillons à une réponse
coordonnée avec nos alliés occidentaux
une réunion s'est tenue lundi entre le
Président de la République le président
américain le chancelier allemand le
Premier ministre britannique et la
présidente du Conseil italien la
ministre des Affaires étrangères
Catherine Colona a également pour suivi
ses contacts et une réunion informelle
des ministres des Affaires étrangères de
l'Union européenne s'est tenue hier
j'ajoute que l'ensemble de notre
diplomatie est mobilisé jour et nuit il
est essentiel de poursuivre ces échanges
pour éviter tout risque d'embrasement
mobiliser tous nos partenaires protéger
les civils et veiller au respect du
droit
international monsieur le Président
patria la France restera toujours
attachée à la paix et nous continuerons
à la défendre et à la rechercher comme
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire la
barbarie de ces attaques terribles ne
doit pas nous faire renoncer à trouver
une solution de paix durable au Proche
Orient et une issue politique dans le
conflit
israélo-palestinien nous aurons besoin
d'une approche complète cela prendra du
temps mais nous ne perdons pas de vue
cet objectif c'est le seul chemin pour
la sécurité et la stabilité dans la
région c'est aussi un chemin pour
l'apaisement dans nos démocratie je vous
remercie la parole est au président
Claude maluré pour le groupe Les
Indépendants République et
territoire mad madame la Première
ministre les images insoutenables de
l'attaque terroriste du Hamas en Israël
imposent une condamnation absolue et une
solidarité totale avec les victimes mais
l'émotion légitime la colère et le
dégoût ne doivent pas nous empêcher bien
au contraire de comprendre les raisons
pour lesquelles elles ont pu se produire
la guerre est revenue et nous ne voulons
pas laavir je ne parle pas seulement de
la guerre du Hamas contre Israël mais
des guerres au Moyen-Orient en Afrique
en mer de Chine et maintenant en Europe
c'est la guerre des dictatures contre
les démocraties elle est mondial les
mains qui ont tranché la gorge des
enfants d'Israël venaient de Gaza mais
le cerveau est à Théron 2008 la Géorgie
2011 la Syrie 2014 la Crimée puis le
Sahel et l'Ukraine 2023 l'Arménie et
aujourd'hui Israël l'international des
dictateurs s'est reformé nous les avions
cru à la fin du 20e siècle ils sont de
retour pour mettre à bas les démocraties
ils ne sont pas unis par une idéologie
ils sont une hydre monstrueuse pouvoir
mafieux en Russie dictature du parti à
Pyongyang et Pékin folie islamiste en
Iran soldatesque galoné au Sahel une sol
idée fixe les rassemble renversé à notre
détriment les règles du jeu mondial
comme chaque fois les démocraties sont
aveugles à la catastrophe annoncé
pas parce que leurs ennemis se cachent
mais parce que nous nous voilons la face
l'Europe a construit une formidable
sphère de prospérité mais elle oublié
qu'il n'y avait pas de prospérité
durable sans puissance et l'Europe
puissance n'existe pas encore ce que
nous devons à toutes les victimes des
attentats en Israël c'est donner un sens
à leur mort c'est qu'il ne soit pas mort
pour rien mais pour nous faire
comprendre que le combat entre les
dictatures et les démocraties est à
nouveau face à nous notre hymne national
nous le dit la liberté liberté chérie ne
peut combattre qu'avec ses défenseur
nous devons nous réarmer militairement
industriellement et surtout surtout
moralement c'est la tâche extrêmement
difficile des gouvernements européens de
votre gouvernement que d'en convaincre
le peuple mais c'est la seule façon
comme nos aînés l'ont fait au siècle
dernier de résister à la
barbarie
[Applaudissements]
pour vous
répondre la parole est à madame la
Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le Président Claude
maluré comme vous j'ai été choqué je
l'ai dit desès dimanches par le
relativisme de certains responsables
politiques et leur ambigué face à ces
actes monstrueux leur refus répété et
assumé d'appeler terroriste une
organisation pourtant reconnue comme
telle et ma conviction c'est que face au
drames terribles qui frappent
Israël notre devoir c'est de veiller à
l'unité nationale à la cohésion
nationale il ne doit y avoir aucune
ambigué face au terrorisme aucune
ambiguïé pour dénoncer la
barbarie sur notre sol nous ne
laisserons passer aucun aucun desbordeau
ni sur la ni sur la voie publique ni
dans l'espace
numérique nos valeurs républicaines ne
sont pas négociables l'antisémitisme ou
l'apologie du terrorisme ne peuvent être
tolérés sous aucune forme nous ferons
preuve de la plus grande fermeté envers
ceux qui veulent faire de cette attaque
le prétexte à des débordements dans nos
rues dans nos écoles dans nos
universités nous serons
inflexibles j'ajoute que nous sommes au
côté des Juifs de France que cette
situation choque et inquiète la
République est avec eux dès samedi le
ministre de l'Intérieur a donné
instruction au préfet de renforcer la
vigilance et la protection des lieux
sensibles et nos services de
renseignement sont à l'œuvre pour
détecter toute menace et je rappelle que
sur proposition de du gouvernement le
Parlement a d'ors et déjà définitivement
adopté deux lois de programmation pour
nos armées pour nos forces de sécurité
intérieure et j'espère que vot votre
assemblée adoptera tout à l'heure la loi
de programmation du ministère de la
Justice nous ne devons pas faire preuve
de naïveté nous devons assurer notre
souveraineté stratégique industrielle
sur tous les plans monsieur le Président
maruré je le redis dans ces heures
graves la seule solution celle qui
protège la démocratie et nos valeurs
c'est la cohésion nationale c'est de la
défense de la République collectivement
l'heure est à la responsabilité à
l'unité c'est ainsi que nous serons à la
hauteur je vous
remerci la parole est à madame la
Présidente Marie scarer pour le groupe
du Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la Première ministre le RDSE
souhaitait s'associer aux autres groupes
du Sénat qui au travers de leurs
interventions ont exprimé leur stupeur
et leur souffrance ressenties à
l'annonce des attaques terroristes du
Hamas en Israël nous tenons à exprimer
toute notre solidarité et notre
tristesse aux familles et aux proches de
ces milliers de victimes innocentes
sauvagement assassinées ou prises en
aotage de telles atrocités engagent la
conscience de la société toute entière
et il ne peut-être laissé de place à la
nuance et à la polémique ces derniers
jours une fois de plus les bombes ont
suivi les obus et les morts ont fait
place à d'autres morts de peuples
souffrent et vont souffrir bien que cela
soit prématuré au regard de l'escalade
et qui risque de se jouer aux abords de
Gaza il faudra rapidement interroger les
responsabilités de chacun dans un
processus de paix à l'arrêt si certains
rapprochements ont laissé entrevoir une
évolution potentiellement favorable je
pense à celui entre l'Arabie Saoudite et
Israël forcé de constater que le drame
d'aujourd'hui oblige à repartir d'une
page blanche clairement nous ne devons
pas fermer les yeux en espérant que le
temps et la nécessité F le travail à
notre place aussi madame la Première
ministre quelles seront demain la
position et l'action de la France au
sein de la communauté internationale
pour aider les peuples Israéliens et
Palestiniens à vivre en paix au-delà de
cet événement insoutenable comment
accélérer de concert avec tous les pays
concernés par le terrorisme dont la
France la lutte contre ce mal récurrent
je terminerai par un extrait du livre de
Yasmin akadra dans les irondelles de
Kabou qui disait zunira s'est égaré le
temps d'une hystérie collective parce
que les horreurs quotidiennes s'avèrent
plus fortes que l'éveil son geste est la
preuve que tout peut basculer sans crier
gare ces mots ne parlent pas d'Israël ou
de la Palestine mais il relate avec
force la fragilité de la paix la
puissance de l'horreur et le danger
permanent de la folie terroriste
aujourd'hui le groupe RDSE souhaitait
juste rappeler cela un hommage à Yael
Lian et noya tombé au kibutz beri le 7
octobre 2023 et à tous les victimes de
ces attentats je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la Présidente Marie
scarer le drame que vit Israël nous
touche
profondément le bilan de cette attaque
terroriste est grave
choquant dans ce contexte nous sommes au
côté du peuple israélien Israël a le
droit de se défendre face au terrorisme
aussi nous prenons toute notre part et
le président de la République et la
ministre des Affaires étrangères
multiplie les échanges pour permettre la
désescalade et éviter tout embrasement
régional à plus long terme notre
position n'a pas changé nous croyons
dans une paix durable et une solution
politique au conflit la France jouera
pleinement son
rôle madame la Présidente au moment où
le droit international est contesté où
les puissances cherchent à s'affirmer
par tous les moyens où les désordres du
monde se multiplient nous devons assurer
notre sécurité
collective la France est mobilisée nous
continuerons à nous battre pour nos
valeurs nous continuerons à défendre le
respect du droit international des
frontières nous continuerons à renforcer
notre souveraineté en France avec des
moyens inédits pour nos armées et nos
services de renseignement
comme en Europe en défendant la
souveraineté stratégique européenne nous
continuerons aussi à défendre le
multilatéralisme et l'aide au
développement nous agissons avec un seul
but des résultats concrets sur le
terrain madame la Présidente carer face
au terrorisme comme pour défendre nos
valeurs la France agit et nous
continuons à répondre présent je vous
remercie parole est maintenant au
président Bruno rotill pour le groupe
des
[Applaudissements]
Républicains monsieur le Président
Madame la première ministre
rien rien de ce qui est inhumain ne doit
nous être étranger et aujourd'hui tous
nous nous sentons tous
israéliens nous nous sautons tous aussi
Arméniens de peuples qui sont liés dans
la destinée tragique par deux génocides
dans le caucas du Sud les plans du
Satrap de Bakou ont réussi sans
quasiment aucune opposition si ce n'est
quelques
gesticulation d'abord un blocus pour
affamer une population pendant de longs
mois dans le haut karabak et puis
ensuite le coup de grâce le coup de
grâce pour achever le travail et jeter
sur les routes d'un exode définitif d'un
exode sans retour près de 110000
arménien 3000 ans presque de présence
arménienne 3000 ans d'histoire balayé
effacé en 3 jours madame la Première
ministre mes questions sont précises et
je sais que vos réponses le seront la
première la première pour vous cette
opération de nettoyage est-elle une
épuration ethnique et puis puisque
désormais l'Arménie est menacée dans sa
souveraineté quelle mesure comptez-vous
prendre pour la protéger et en
particulier comptez-vous dénoncer
l'accord cééra de Bacou qu'à signer
Madame Van derle yen en dépit des
sanctions puisquon sait que ce gaz vient
pour parti de Moscou merci de vos
réponses pour vous répondre la parole
est à madame la Première ministre merci
monsieurés Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Bruno
rotaillot le sud Caucase est touché par
des événement d'une immense gravité et
le contexte et l'horreur que nous
connaissons depuis samedi ne doivent pas
nous le faire oublier en quelques jours
des familles ont dû quitter leurs
maisons et leurs terre ancestral un
exode massif de plus de 100000 Arméniens
du hautkabach a été
organisé monsieur le président taillot
je connais votre attachement à l'Arménie
et à la défense du peuple arménien et
comme vous je partage l'émotion et le
choc face à ce drame dès le début la
France a été en première ligne nous
avons fermement condamné l'attitude de
l'Azerbaïdjan la ministre de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères s'est rendu à
ervan le 3 octobre nous apportons notre
plein soutien politique aux autorités
arméniennes pour que leur intégrité
territoriale leur souveraineté et
inviolabilité de leurs frontières ne
soit à aucun moment remise en question
sur le plan humanitaire nous avons
triplé notre aide afin d'aider l'Arménie
à accueillir les milliers de réfugiés du
haut carabach comme l'a dit le président
de la République à Grenade nous
soutenons le renforcement de la
coopération de l'Union européenne avec
l'Arménie monsieur le Président
retaillot je le rappelle le président
azerbaïdjanais avait pris l'engagement
clair de ne pas faire us de la force
dans le haut carabak c'était à Prague en
octobre 2022 lors de la première réunion
de la comité la communauté politique
européenne force de constater que cet
engagement n'a pas été tenu pour sortir
de cette crise nous nous plaidons bien
sûr pour que l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïjan
se parle une réunion se se tiendra d'ici
la fin du mois à Bruxelles sous lesgit
de Charles Michel nous serons
extrêmement vigilants quant à attitude
qui tiendra le président alief ces
discussions doivent permettre de
parvenir à un accord de paix respectueux
du droit international nous ne
transigerons pas sur ce point enfin tout
en écartant toute logique d'escalade
nous avons renforcé notre coopération de
défense avec l'Arménie et je vous
confirme que nous avons décidé
d'autoriser la fourniture de matériel
militaire pour que l'Arménie soit en
mesure d'assurer sa défense ainsi que
l'a indiqué le président de la
République hier nous voulons continuer à
échanger avec les acteurs pour protéger
au mieux l'Arménie et appeler
l'Azerbaïdjan à la responsabilité je
vous
remercie président arrêtez madame la
Première ministre de mettre sur le même
plan le bourreau et la victime l'Arménie
et l'azerbachan le 21 février prochain
le président de la République fera
rentrer au Panthéon missac
Manouchian un orphelin du gén a
d'Arménien et il y entrera dans ce
temple de la gloire nationale accompagné
de son terrible cortège de ses frères
d'armes tout ce qui était comme l'a dit
et écrit Aragon des Français de
préférence qui avaient rejoint la
Résistance il y rentrera aussi
accompagné de cet épouvantable clameur
anonyme de toutes ces vies broyé oublié
écrasé par le génocide et qui du fond de
leur tombe nous demande vous demande
implore la protection de la France
pour le peuple d'aujourd'hui et bien
quand le président de la République au
moment même où il fera son discours il
célébrera l'héroïsme le courage de
missac manoucian peut-être peut-être
pensera-t-il avec quelques regret à ce
même courage qui aujourd'hui fait tant
défaut pour être à la hauteur de
[Applaudissements]
l'histoire
en l'tat notre collègue Gilbert Luc
devinas pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
[Applaudissements]
républicain merci monsieur le
Président mes interrogations
s'inscrivent dans le prolongement du
propos du président Bruno rotaillon
depuis 4 ans nous attirons l'attention
de l'exécutif
sur les menaces des présidents alief et
Erdogan ce dernier déclarait en 2020
vouloir je cite continuer d'accomplir la
mission de nos grands-parents il a fallu
24 heur 24 heur à l'Azerbaïjan pour
faire disparaître et tuer la démocratie
d'artsat je tiens à saluer les actions
de solidarité des diasporas notamment
françaises de nos collectivités
territoriales des fondations et
associations je salue aussi la CAPAC
cité de mobilisation des Arméniens de la
ville de Goris qui font temps à de
besoins et de détresse je salue la
résolution du Parlement européen qui
soulligne entre autres que les principes
internationaux ont été bafoués par
l'Azerbaïjan enfin je salue madame la
ministre vos propos tenu à ervan oui la
France doit aider l'Arménie à assurer
son intégrité territoriale notamment en
renforçant sa capacité de défense c'est
ce que suggère la deè résolution du
Sénat votée il y a 1 an c'est une
condition nécessaire pourutant
insuffisante trois interrogations
qu'envisage la France et son
gouvernement pour obtenir la libération
des dirigeants du feu la République
d'artsat arrêté comme terroriste alors
qu'ils ont dirigés incarné au caucas sud
les valeurs démocratiques que nous
entendons comme les nôtres qu'envisage
la France sur le Pr européen pour faire
arrêter cette fourniture de gaz par
l'Azerbaïdjan gaz provenant de Russie le
temps n'est pas aux sanctions a déclaré
notre président à Grenade quand
sera-t-il temps de sanctionner et de
faire mettre fin à cette hypocrisie
insupportable répondre la parole est à
Madame la Ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères madame
colon merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs dans
ces jours particulièrement difficiles
pour
l'Arménie nous sommes pleinement
mobilisés à ses côtés et au côté du
peuple arménien madame la Première
ministre a redit notre engagement notre
engagement constant et c'est aussi celui
que nous portons auprès de nos
partenaires au Conseil de sécurité et
jusqu'à yevan où je suis allé en effet
la semaine dernière personne ne fait
autant pour l'Arménie que la France
madame la Première ministre a rempli a
rappelé les les grandes lignes de notre
action pour aider l'Arménie et pour
empêcher toute remise en cause de son
intégrité territoriale je veux vous dire
que tous les engagements que nous avons
pris seront tenus les 12 millions
d'euros et demi d'aide humanitaire sont
en cours de distribution sur le terrain
à des acteurs engagés auprès des
réfugiés et déplacés en Arménie nous
avons pu évacuer ce weekend qure blessés
graves qui sont accueillis désormais
dans les structures hospitalières
d'Île-de-France des discussions sont en
cours madame la Première ministre la
confirmé pour permettre à l'Arménie
d'acquérir du matériel militaire à
vocation défensive au niveau européen
nous avons proposé avec l'Allemagne un
ambitieux plan de soutien à l'Arménie
qui sera évoqué à notre prochain conseil
le 23 octobre avec notamment l'objectif
de renforcer la mission d'observation
européenne dans ses moyens comme dans
son mandat et à l'ONU enfin monsieur le
sénateur après avoir obtenu une réunion
du Conseil de sécurité demander la
libération des personnes arrêtées
rappeler le droit des Arméniens à vivre
dans le haut carabach nous allons
continuer de rappeler le conseil à ses
responsabilité en vue de progresser vers
un projet de résolution et vous le voyez
nous sommes au côté de l'Arménie et nous
ne permettrons pas que son avenir soit
déterminé par la force ou par la menace
de l'usage de la force je vous
remercie
mer la parole est à notre collègue Marc
Philippe d'bress pour le groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains depuis plus de 3 ans j'ai
régulièrement interpellé vos
prédécesseurs qui se sont succédés à
rythme soutenu d'ailleurs sur la
situation de la construction neuve dans
notre pays pour réclamer en vaain un
plan d'urgence j'ai même eu un entretien
en tête à-tête d'une vingtaine de
minutes avec le président de la
République où j'ai pu mesurer qu'il
avait sous-estimé complètement le
problème cette fois nous y sommes la
construction de logement s'effondre et
vous avez choisi de regarder ailleurs
pourtant les chiffres que vous venez de
publier sont accablants le pire ratio de
construction neuve par rapport aux
demandes des ménages depuis
1950 à la fin de l'année prochaine
250000 constructions neuves la moitié ce
qui est nécessaire pour loger nos
compatriotes c'est-à-dire 300000
chômeurs de plus à la fin de l'année
prochaine dans le BTP tous les secteurs
sont en panne depuis la promotion privée
qui ne vend plus rien jusqu'au logement
social que vous avez tué par votre
funeste réforme des allocations logement
en passant par l'accession à la
propriété où les Primot accédants ne
peuvent plus Primot accéder et au
logement étudiant tout récemment
désormais réservés aux enfants de
famille aisées cette crise touche à la
fois le neuf et l'ancien en particulier
à cause de la bureaucratie de la loi sur
les diagnostics énergétiques et de la
loisane elle touche à la fois l'offre et
la demande à cause de la montée
exponentielle des taux d'intérêt quel
que soit le scénario envisagé c'est donc
bien une catastrophe annoncée dont je
vous parle en réponse après de longs
mois de dénis vous votre Ministre de
tutelle monsieur Béchu appelle à un choc
de décentralisation ce n'est pas filant
la patate chaude aux collectivités
locales sans plan de relance que vous
allez résoudre le problème même l'ancien
Premier ministre Édouard Philippe vient
de sonner l'alarme en vous demandant de
desserrer les taux du logement ma
question est donc simple monsieur le
ministre quand allez-vous vous réveiller
pour éviter la bombe sociale que vous
prédit Édouard
Philippe
ENL ministre délégué chargé du logement
monsieur
Verget monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrice et sénateur
monsieur le sénateur Marc Philippe
dobress la crise du logement aujourd'hui
était prévisible puisqu'on savait
effectivement que le prix du foncier
avait fortement augmenté entraaînant les
prix immobiliers je rappelle dans
certaines grandes villes plus 200 % de
croissance des prix immobiliers et ça
s'expliquait tout simplement par des
taux extrêmement bas qui sont restés
pendant de nombreuses années plus d'une
quinzaine d'années de taux bas et donc
ces taux très bas sont intégrés
aujourd'hui maintenant dans le prix du
foncier c'est ça qui provoque
aujourd'hui la crise du logement avec la
remontée des taux d'intérêt et le coût
des
matériaux le travail que nous opérons
aujourd'hui avec le gouvernement vise à
travailler sur l'ensemble des éléments
qui permettent de relancer la la demande
nous avons d'abord travaillé sur la
question du logement social et vous le
savez puisque vous avez dû sans doute
suivre le Congrès HLM la semaine passée
à Nantes nous avons trouvé un accord
avec le mouvement HLM pour pouvoir à la
fois réussir le double objectif de la
relance de la production de logement
social et en même temps tenir le
calendrier des rénovations énergétiques
avec 1,2 milliards apportés par le
gouvernement sur 3 ans pour la
rénovation énergétique avec 6 milliards
de prês de la Caisse des dépôts pour
accompagner cette rénovation énergétique
et de l'autre côté du côté de la
production plus 150 millions de prêt
participatifs de la Caisse des Dépôts 8
milliards de prêt de la Caisse des
dépôts à des taux bodifiés cet accord a
été jugé très positif par le mouvement
HLM et permettra je le pense de relancer
c'est à la fois la production et de
tenir le calendrier des rénovations nous
travaillons actuellement sur le prê àaux
zéro et la relance de l'accession à la
propriété en renforçant le dispositif
dans les zones tendues là où il y en a
le plus besoin en le maintenant sur
l'accession sociale dans zones détendu
nous travaillons également sur le
logement locatif intermédiaire et en
particulier la possibilité d'ouvrir aux
institutionnels ce logement locatif
intermédiaire aujourd'hui nous
travaillons sur le foncier Thomas
casaznav l'a évoqué récemment avec la
possibilité de faire un choc d'offre
foncière pour libérer d'avantage de
fonciè bref monsieur le sénateur nous
sommes en train de travailler sur
l'ensemble des fondamentaux de la
politique du logement je vous
remercie parole est à non non non non
vous n'avez plus de temps la parole est
à notre collègue Stéphane Demilly pour
le groupe de l'Union centriste merci
monsieur le Président bonjour madame la
ministre des Affaires
étrangères je sais bien que l'actualité
en chasse une autre et que nos regards
et et nos cœurs sont aujourd'hui
mobilisés à quelques exceptions près par
le peuple israélien victime d'une
impensable barbarie
moyenageuse je sais bien que le monopoie
Mondial est complexe et que l'Europe au
regard du contexte ukrainien avait
besoin de diversifier ses importations
de gaz ce qui rapporte des milliards à
l'Azerbaidjan nos collègues rotayo et
devvinas en ont parlé tout cela nous le
savons néanmoins je souhaite moi aussi
revenir sur la situation dramatique du
haut cararabak comme en Ukraine comme à
Gaza comme dans de nombreux endroits de
de la planète la force prévaut sur le
droit faut-il madame la ministre qu'un
peuple disparaisse pour savoir qu'il
existe
80 % de la population arménienne a dû
abandonner du jour au lendemain la terre
qu'elle habite depuis 2500 ans pour ne
pas se faire massacrer et ce après avoir
été encerclé et affamé la Russie a
renoncé à protéger l'Arménie et nous
Européens avons poussé le cynisme
jusqu'à inviter le Premier ministre
arménien Nicole
a négocié avec ses agresseurs chacun
sait que c'est facile de négocier avec
un couteau sous la gorge chacun sait que
c'est facile de négocier avec un
président qui promet je cite de vous
chasser comme des chiens
charlesasdinvour incanté dans une de ces
chansons après l'horreur après la peur
pour toi Arménie le monde s'est levé le
monde est avec toi alors madame la
ministre la France est-elle avec
l'Arménie madame la ministre la France
se lève-t-elle pour l'Arménie au-delà
des mots de compassion et au-delà des
condamnations diplomatiques de
circonstances qu'envisage de faire la
France pour le peuple arménien qui a
connu le premier génocide du 20e siècle
et qui vit actuellement sous nos yeux le
premier nettoyage ethnique du 21e
siècle parole est à Madame la Ministre
de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères merci Monsieur Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
chacun bien s dans cette micycle mesure
la la gravité de la crise qui se déroule
au au Proche Orient mais ne saurait nous
faire détourner le regarde la situation
dans le sudcaucase et en Arménie en
effet quel que soit la manière dont il
cherche à présenter la situation oui
l'Azerbaïdjan a planifié et organisé
l'exode de plus de 100000 Arméniens du
haut cararabach il s'agit d'acte d'une
extrême gravité de CRIM et de crimes qui
ne peuvent rester sans réaction nous
avons organisé un nouveau débat au
Conseil de sécurité nous lui demandons
aujourd'hui de prendre ses
responsabilités pour une résolution qui
permette de créer les conditions d'un
possible retour des populations
arméniennes du haut carabach cela passe
par des garanties des garanties fermes
du respect de leurs droits historique et
culturelle et par une présence
internationale permanente qui est
l'objet de tous nos efforts madame la
Première ministre a rappeler tout à
l'heure et je l'ai fait à sa suite
l'ensemble de ce que nous faisons pour
aider l'Arménie le redit comme aucun
autre pays ne le fait not conviction
comme l'a dit la première ministre c'est
bien que les questions en suspens entre
l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïjan ne pourront
trouver de solution que par un processus
négocié et par une paix juste et durable
c'est la raison pour laquelle la France
soutient les efforts de médiation de
l'Union européenne soutien qui est un
soutien exigeant qui ne fera aucune
concession sur le nécessaire respect du
droit international de la la
souveraineté et de l'intégrité
territoriale de l'Arménie et en
parallèle oui nous devons continuer de
soutenir l'Arménie comme nous le faisons
et de dissuader l'Azerbaïjan avec
quelques messages qui lui sont adressés
y compris ce qui a été confirmé
aujourd'hui le dissuader de poursuivre
dans la voie de la force il n'y a pas
d'alternative possible pour assurer la
paix au bénéfice de toutes les
populations dans le sud Caucase je vous
[Applaudissements]
remercie il vous resta quelques
la parole est à notre collègue Christine
bonvanti d'sa pour le groupe des
républiains merci merci monsieur le
président monsieur le garde des saau
vous n'êtes pas sans ignorer la
situation d'une grande majorité des
agents du GREF partout en France qui
estime que leur légitime revendication
n'est pas prise en compte et je sais que
vous vous en préoccupé mais après votre
récent déplacement à Grenoble il demeure
encore des des divergences entre leurs
revendication et celle des
syndicats cette profession mise à rue
d'épreuve depuis déjà fort longtemps
réclame finalement une réforme
indispensable à son statut catégorielle
une revalorisation en conséquence
salariale en conséquence mais également
une meilleure reconnaissance de sa
fonction au sein de l'institution
judiciaire ces
négociations visent simplement à
rééquilibrer leur statut en fonction des
deux autres directions de votre
ministère euh ce qu'il demande en
réalité monsieur le ministre c'est une
réforme d'équité mais au fond cette
situation n'est que le reflet des
difficultés de recrutement que rencontre
la fonction publique et plus
particulièrement les ministères
régaliens qui n'ont pas su
enrayer la démotivation d'un nombre
important d'agents et ce n'est pas le
recours fréquent à des des agents
contractuels qui va leur redonner
confiance alors monsieur le ministre
vous savez combien le Sénat est attaché
à cette fonction nous avons uvré avec
force pour la trajectoire de recrutement
de 1800 greffiers pouvez-vous me dire
alors où en sont réellement ces
négociations et quand est-ce qu'elles
vont enfin
aboutir la parole est à Monsieur le Gard
des saau monsieur Dupont morti merci
Monsieur le présid prident mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Bonfanti d'ossage je tout
d'abord vous féliciter de façon
républicaine et chaleureuse pour votre
réélection ainsi que pour l'élection ou
la réélection de toutes les sénatrices
et
sénateur votre question madame la
sénatrice me permet de raflerer une fois
encore qu'il y a pas de justice sans
greffier depuis 2022 un greffier en
milieu de carrière a bénéficié d'une
augmentation de
294 € brut mensuel soit plus 13 % de sa
rémunération mais mais ça n'est pas
suffisant j'avais annoncé dans un
calendrier dédié à l'automne un certain
nombre de mesures nouvelles mais comme
vous le dites et vous avez raison il y a
un certain nombre de divergences entre
les greffiers eux-mêmes sur ce qu'il
souhaitent et dans l'expression des
différents syndicats qui viennent au
soutien de leurs intérêts alors les axes
de discussion et le protocole d'accord
contiendra trois axes en réalité
revalorisation statutaire des greffiers
de catégorie B+ ça doit intervenir fin
2023 création d'un corps de greffier de
catégorie A c'est inédit ça concerne 25
% du
corps enfin un plan de requalification
des agents de catégorie C faisant
fonction de greffier ce qui permettra à
700 agents de catégorie C de devenir
greffier et de reconnaître ainsi
l'expérience qu'ils ont acquise je vous
annonce madame la sénatrice que je
souhaite signer ce protocole avec les
syndicats d'ici une quinzaine de jours
je souhaite également ardemment que le
Sénat dans quelques minutes adopte la
lobgie ce qui nous permettra bien sûr
d'envoyer dans les juridictions 1800
greffier de plus et concernant agin
ville qui vous tient particulièrement à
cœur j'ai demandé au directeur des
services judiciaires de se déplacer
demain pour rencontrer les greffiers et
leur faire part des évolutions qui sont
en
cours merci merci Monsieur le gardess
pour ces paroles encourageantes
j'accepte l'augure qu'elle rassureront
tous les agents du GREF afin qu'il n ait
plus d'injustice dans la justice
la parole est à notre collègue Colomb
brossell pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre de l'Éducation
nationale ma question porte sur le bilan
de votre rentrée scolaire car derrière
votre plan de communication permanent il
y a des chiffres des constats des
réalités ils sont cruel cruel pour vous
mais surtout cruel pour les élèves leurs
enseignants les personnels éducatifs qui
on paient tous le prix cette rentrée
scolaire c'est la rentrée de
l'impréparation c'est la rentrée des
engagements nontenu fin août vous
annonciez un professeur devant chaque
classe il n'en est rien dans des
académies entières des enseignants ont
été nommés et affectés plusieurs jours
après la rentrée quittant du jour au
lendemain leurs classe et leurs élèves
pour aller retrouver leur affectation
définitive de même des milliers de
lycéens souvent en voie professionnelle
ou technologique attendent encore le 11
octobre une
affectation enfin alors que 288000
enfants en situation de handicap
scolarisé en milieu ordinaire ont besoin
d'un accompagnement la moitié d'entre
n'a aucun accompagnement le 3 octobre
dernier les aesh étaient d'ailleurs en
grève voilà un tableau bien noir face à
des urgences qui s'accumulent alors
monsieur le ministre que répondez-vous
aux parents et aux élèves qui font face
à la chaise vide de leur enseignants aux
enseignants qui méritent plus que des
primes conditionnées à l'exercice de
mission complémentaire ou aux AES qui
veulent enfin être reconnu pour leur
travail
indispensable la parole est au ministre
de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse Monsieur
hatal Merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la
sénatrice vous abordez la rentrée
scolaire dans votre question et pour
vous répondre je voudrais commencer vous
n'avez pas jugé bon de le faire par
remercier et saluer les enseignants les
chefs d'établissements les agents d'
rectorat qui ont organisé cette rentrée
au service des élèves et des
familles madame la sénatrice évidemment
il y a des difficultés évidemment qu'il
y a oui c'est vrai des difficultés dans
notre système scolaire évidemment
simplement je veux rappeler quelques
réalités la première réalité c'est que
depuis 2017 il y a 300000 élèves de
moins dans notre système scolaire et que
si on avait suivi cette démographie on
aurait supprimé autour de 20000 postes
on en a créé 2000 300000 élèves de moins
2 2000 postes en plus 300000 élèves de
moins depuis 2017 et pourtant une
augmentation du budget de 30 % ça ne
s'était jamais vu dans les précédents
quinquena oui il y a des difficultés
mais nous investissons comme jamais pour
l'éducation nationale vous avez abordé
le la rémunération des enseignants oui
c'était dû cette revalorisation des
enseignants mais elle n'est pas comme
vous l'avez dit conditionnée à des
missions supplémentaires tous les
enseignants ont connu une revalorisation
sans contrepartie encore à cette rentrée
si vous comparez la rentrée 2022
septembre 2022 à septembre 2023 c'est
entre 125 et 250 € nets de plus pour
tous les enseignants de rentrer à
rentrer entre le point d'indice et la
revalorisation chocle qui a eu lieu en
cette rentrée vous parlez de l'école
inclusive et des aesh nous avons
quasiment doublé le nombre d'élèves qui
sont accueillis à l'école et nous avons
recruté 40000 à es nous les revalorisons
de 13 % encore en 7ette rentrée
évidemment on n'est pas au bout des
problèmes on doit maintenant améliorer
qualitativement l'accueil des élèves et
c'est le travail qu'on a engagé avec mes
ab a berger pour continuer à avancer oui
il y a des difficultés mais oui nous
investissons comme jamais et je suis
absolument convaincu que nous viendrons
au bout de ces difficultés avec les
enseignants avec les chefs
d'établissement les aesh avec les
familles parce que nous voulons tous je
le crois la réussite de notre école au
service de nos
élèves madame
Bross merci monsieur le Président j'ai
trop de respect pour cette assemblée
pour céder à la démagogie alors Tom
jasm sont des enfants qui n'ont pas fait
leur rentrée car ce sont des enfants en
situation de handicap qui ne sont pas
rentrés à l'école en cette rentrée
Guillaume Abdel fatumata sont des
lycéens qui n'ont pas fait leur rentrée
parce qu'ils n'ont pas eu d'affectation
à cette rentrée et tant que le
gouvernement considérera que ce sont des
sujets de statistique et bien nous nous
continuerons à porter la parole de ces
enfants de ces élèves partout et y
compris dans cette
[Applaudissements]
émicicle
parole est à notre collègue Vivette
Lopez pour le groupe des
Républicains merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues j'associe à ma question
mon collègue Alain Châtillon monsieur le
ministre je suis très surprise enfin je
ne devrais pas depuis le temps je dirais
plutôt scandalisé de constater qu'en
France lorsque l'on est vertueux que
l'on est prudent et économe l'état
beaucoup moins vertueux n'hésite pas à
venir se servir pour en récupérer les
fruits et c'est ce que vous vous
apprêtez à faire avec les retraite
complémentairire agir
Arco les réserves accumulées ont été
constituées par un effort soutenu des
salariés et sont le fruit d'une gestion
raisonnable elles assurent sur le long
terme la retraite des salariés du privé
faute de conduire des réformes
courageuses pour ramener les finances
publiques à l'équilibre vous allez pour
la deuxème fois pill les caisses de
l'agir AR ces réserves n'appartiennent
donc pas à votre gouvernement aussi
Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous nous
rassurer et nous garantir que les
réserves financières de ces régimes
complémentaires ne feront pas l'objet
d'un prélèvement
indu ministre du Travail du plein emploi
de l'insertion monsieur
Lop merci monsieur le président madame
la sénatrice vous m'interrogez sur euh
la caisse complémentaire à girir Carco
et sur les perspectives financières de
celle-ci d'abord je voudrais vous
rejoindre sur un point cette caisse est
bien gérée elle est bien gérée
puisqu'elle dégage des excédents et elle
dégage elle dégage d'autant plus
d'excédents que depuis 2019 parce que
cela a été voté par les partenaires
sociaux une décote de une décote
temporaire de 10 % est appliquée et plus
d'un salarié sur deux parti à la
retraite depuis 2019 et bénéficiant de
cette CAE de retraite a été touché par
la décotte nous avons présenté la
réforme des retraites avec madame la
Première ministre il y a quelques mois à
tous les toutes les étapes de la
concertation nous avons dit aux
partenaires sociaux que cette réforme
était une réforme de retour à
l'équilibre tout régime confondu nous
savons aujourd'hui que laagir carcoov va
continuer à dégager des excédents et
nous savons qu'à horizon 2026 parmi les
excédents sur le total des excédents et
nous ne parlons surtout pas des réserves
mais uniquement des excédents annuels
sur le total des excédents de 2026 1
milliard d' d'excédents sont dus à la
réforme des retraites qui a été adopté
au printemps dernier
nous considérons qu'il y a 1ard2
millions d'euros qui vont bénéficier à
GIR Carco en 2026 uniquement par la
réforme et nous considérons comme
légitime que cette part des excédents
liés à la réforme puisse être mobilisé
pour participer au financement d'un
régime de solidarité les partenaires
sociaux ont mis en œuvre une discussion
sur les règles de gestion de la GIR
Carco et ont fait un choix différent
choix différent qui se traduit au même
horizon 2026 par une augmentation des
dépenses sociales et donc des dépenses
publiques au sens de la loi organique
d'un milliard d'euros supplémentaires
nous nous devons faire face donc à deux
défis le premier défi c'est voir comment
nous pouvons rééquilibrer les finances
public pour faire face à 1 milliard
d'euros de dépenses supplémentaires et
nous considérons que ça n'est pas une
attitude totalement responsable nous
devons faire face à un second défi qui
est de garantir que la réforme que vous
avez voté qui est mise en œuvre soit une
réforme de retour à l'équilibre du
régime de
retraite
l monsieur le ministre sachez que ce
prélèvement est perçu comme en raquette
la solidarité financière n'est pas
entendable ce n'est pas au retraité du
privé de payer le gaspillage de l'État
en outre la fonction demandée par l'État
met en danger la pérennité des retraites
complémentaires et l'avenir des
relations sociales aussi si d'aventure
le gouvernement passait par la loi de
financement de sécurité sociale pour en
obtenir le versement nous serons là et
nous engagerons notre responsabilité
pour garantir l'avenir des relations
sociales et la pérennité des
complémentaire la parole est à notre
collègue marido etliman pour le groupe
les
[Applaudissements]
républicains merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre des solidarités et
des familles le dynamisme de la natalité
française a longtemps été une exception
à modèle or comme sur tant d'autres
sujets la France décline depuis 2011 la
natal ité est en chute libre dans notre
pays et vous regardez ailleurs l'INC
vient malheureusement de confirmer une
nouvelle fois une nouvelle baisse de la
natalité et 2023 pourrait être la pire
année depuis 1945 avec seulement 700000
naissances les raisons on les connaît
c'est d'abord le démantellement de la
politique familiale sous François
Hollande baisse du cotient familial de
la
page modulation des allocations en
fonction des revenus parentaux plafon
des ressources congés parental
insuffisant depuis 2017 malgré diverses
annonces rien n'a été fait pour soutenir
les familles et leur redonner confiance
promesse de créer des places en crèche
rendu veine par l'étranglement financier
des communes manque de personnel
qualifié gelle des prestations
familiales au fond avec la fin
deuniversalité la politique familiale
est devenue une politique
essentiellement sociale qui ne compense
plus la charge de l' entretien et de
l'éducation de l'enfant parce
qu'accueillir un enfant engage et dépend
de la façon dont on se projette dans
l'avenir emploi logement sécurité
financière anxiété climatique c'est
aujourd'hui votre responsabilité alors
si cette chute de la natalité nous
inquiète elle devrait vous obséder ce
qui est en jeu ce n'est ni plus ni moins
que la survie de la France car relever
le défi de la natalité c'est bien sûr
préserver notre modèle social c'est
faire perdurer notre culture et notre
identité c'est aussi et surtout rester
maître de notre destin national au vu de
tous ces enjeux la politique familiale
devrait redevenir une priorité nationale
madame la ministre je sais que vous
partagez peu au prou ces constats alors
que comptez-vous faire pour concrètement
enrayer le déclin démograque
démographique de la France à quand une
vraie politique familiale généreuse
ambitieuse qui soutient toutes les
familles et renoue avec notre histoire
notre modèle je vous
remercie
ministre des Solidarités et des famill
madame Rore
[Musique]
berger merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice et permettez-moi de
vous féliciter pour votre élection les
mots que vous avez tenu je pourrais les
reprendre pas peu ou prou les reprendre
intégralement parce que vous avez raison
la baisse de laentalité dans notre pays
elle devrait tous en fait nous obséder
parce que quand on parle des grandes
transitions qui sont devant nous la
transition évidemment écologique et
énergétique il y a aussi la question de
la transition démographique nous avons
d'un côté le choc démographique devant
nous la question du vieillissement de la
population mais nous ne pouvons pas
avoir dans le même temps ce risque de
baisse de la natalité que nous
constatons comme vous l'avez relevé
depuis 2011 et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous devons réaffirmer ce que
doit être la politique familiale dans
notre pays une politique familiale
universelle au service de toutes les
familles et qui vient donc en soutien de
la la démographie et de la natalité
c'est ça l'objectif même de la politique
familiale qui a été créée et pensé dans
l'après-guerre et avec laquelle nous
devons évidemment renouer en tout cas
c'est l'objectif qui m'a été confié par
le Président de la République et par la
première ministre alors qu'est-ce que
nous devons faire vous l'avez dit nous
devons agir à la fois sur les
prestations familiales pour qu'avant
corriger avant de corriger les
inégalités elles soit en soutien de
l'ensemble évidemment des familles de
notre pays nous devons agir sur les
freins périphériques évidents qui
continuent à exister qui font
qu'aujourd'hui le désir d'enfant dans
notre pays n'est pas en adéquation avec
le nombre d'enfants que les Français ont
et cela a des causes des causes
sanitaires c'est la question de
l'infertilité qui ne doit plus être un
tabou dans notre pays mais sur lequel
nous devons avoir une véritable
politique c'est la question de la garde
d'enfants parce qu'aujourd'hui nous le
savons trop de familles n'arrivent pas à
réaliser leur désir d'enfant parce
qu'ils sont angoissés sur ce sujet c'est
la réforme que nous souhaitons porter
notamment vous le savez sur la question
du congé parental pour faire en sorte
que les familles et plus plus de temps
avec leurs enfants bref c'est un
chantier majeur que nous devons ouvrir
et que j'espère bien pouvoir ouvrir avec
vous Madame la
sénatriceci la parole est à Monsieur
ravier pour la Réunion administrative
des séndateurs ne figurant sur la liste
d'aucun groupe vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Intérieur le
Hamas c'est une organisation terroriste
fondée par la confréie des Frères
musulmans en France comme en Israël il
massacre sans pitié hommes femmes et
enfants c'est les Frères musulmans qui
vivent parmi nous à cause de la folle
politique d'immigration que vous avez
tous soutenu ici mes chers collègues par
faiblesse ou par conviction il faut les
traiter comme en Israël par une réplique
radicale et impitoyable si certains s'y
refusent moi je le dis clairement ma
haine ils l'ont cette guerre nous a été
déclarée par les islamistes depuis des
années il y a 10 ans déjà un de leurs
soldats assassiné des enfants dans une
école juive et des militaires à Toulouse
et à Montauban depuis des jeunes des
caricaturistes des prêtres des femmes
libres des policiers un professeur ont
été massacrés sur notre sol ils
assassinent méthodiquement et froidement
tous ceux qui font la France tout ce qui
fait notre civilisation car c'est bien
d'une guerre de civilisation dont il
s'agit ici comme à Marseille je dénonce
depuis des années les conséquences de
votre immigrationnisme les activités des
islamistes dans ma ville de ces mosquées
assujetti au Frères musulmans jusqu'au
collège financé par l'Arabie Saoudite
qu'en avez-vous fait monsieur le
ministre rien il continue de prospérer
grâce à l'immigration massive et à sa
natalité toujours plus conquérente alors
puisqu'en matière d'antisémitisme et
plus globalement en matière de
protection de tous les Français monsieur
le ministre vous êtes censé ne rien
laisser passer allez-vous dissoudre les
Frères musulmans et tous les organismes
toutes les mosquées toutes les
associations qui se réclamament de cette
pensée et à cette réplique immédiate il
faut une politique de fond allez-vous
enfin non seulement stopper mais aussi
inverser le courant de l'immigration une
immigration qui alimente on le sait le
soutien du Hamas chez nous allez-vous
expulser tous les étrangers qui
soutiennent le Hamas allez-vous ordonner
la dissolution de tous les collabos du
Hamas des Indigènes de la République on
NPA de la CGT 13 au syndicat Sud en
passant par l'organisation de la
jeunesse des communistes de mon
département pourtant sous l'autorité
d'un de nos collègues monsieur Baky
allez-vous mettre hors d'état de nuire
cette 5è colonne car chez nous monsieur
le ministre la gangraine est déjà
partout et la gangraine on l'élimine ou
on en
crève pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur ravier peut-être pourrions-nous
dans ce moment si terrible pour nos
compatriotes ceux qui vivent dans leur
chair les attaques terroristes du Hamas
en Israël ceux qui s'inquiètent pour
leur famill pour nos compatriotes de
confession juives bien évidemment qui
sont sur notre territoire nationale don
je rappelle que c'est la première
communauté d'Europe et la troème
communauté juive du monde peut-être que
nous pourrions tous en tant que
responsable politique et ça s'adresse
autant qu'à vous que àfi de ne pas faire
autant de parallèles politicien pour
importer chez nous le conflit désastreux
ignoble qui touche les Israéliens
peut-être là serait-ce une phrase
d'abord de responsable politique plutôt
que d'essayer de vivre des problèmes
comme vous le faites manifestement
peut-être qu'un peu de dessence quand
des bébés quand des femmes quand des
vieillards sont massacré pourriez-vous
arrêter quelques instants de faire des
tractes pour Monsieur éc
Zemour
nous en avons terminé avec les questions
au Gouvernement merci mesdames et
messieurs les ministres les prochaines
questions d'actualité auront lieu le
mercredi 18 octobre à 15h la séance sera
reprise à
16h45 pour les conclusion de la
commission mixte paritaire sur le projet
de loi d'orientation et de programmation
du ministère de la Justice ainsi que la
commission mixte paritaire sur le projet
de loi relatif à l'ouverture à la
modernisation et à la responsabilité du
corps judiciaire notre séance est
suspendue voilà pour cette séance de
question au gouvernement qui vous l'avez
vu a été marqué par de très nombreuses
questions autour de la situation
d'Israël et d'ailleurs il était dans la
tribune d'honneur he pendant cette
séance de questions au gouvernement il
est à présent avec Quentin Calmet il
s'agit de Raphaël morave l'ambassadeur
d'Israël en France on l'écoute au micro
de Quentin salle des
conférences bonjour Raphael morave merci
d'accorder à public sa une interview
vous avez assisté aux questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement un mot pour
commencer sur les propos de Gérard
Larcher le président du Sénat qui a
parlé de ces crimes contre l'humanité
qui ont touché des israéliens dans les
kibuts ces mots sont important à vos
yeux sont très importants et bien sûr je
m'associe par complètement je crois que
il il faut appeler un chat un chat et il
faut dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont et il s'agit de CRIM contre
l'humanité vous aimeriez que le
gouvernement français reprenne ce terme
on a entendu la droite sénatoriale
appeler le gouvernement français à
utiliser cette expression et à la faire
utiliser aussi par les partenaires
européens selon vous c'est quelque chose
d'important qui doit se jouer maintenant
je pense que c'est approprié et ce
serait important de oui de décrire les
choses tes que sont la première ministre
qui a évoquer le bilan des
ressortissants français décédés ils sont
10 à l'heure où l'on se parle 18
français n'ont encore pas donné de
nouvelles est-ce que vous avez des des
détails notamment sur le sort d'enfant
parmi ces 18 ressortissants qui sont
disparu malheureusement non j'espère
pouvoir fournir des plus de
renseignements dans le futur mais pour
l'instant nous sommes à la recherche de
des disparus pour savoir quel est quel
est leur sort et bien sûr dans la mesure
du possible le sort des des otages oui
est-ce que vous avez un décompte
notamment du nombre de personnes
disparues aussi en Israël un décompte
précis alors pas encore parce que
justement on n pas encore déterminé le
sort de tous les disparus s'ils sont
morts ou s'ils sont
euh sans contact ou s ils sont vraiment
pris en otage eu que dire de cette
polémique autour de la France insoumise
on a entendu le chef de fil des
socialistes ici au Sénat Patrick canner
parler d'une indignité à propos bien de
cette distinction que font les insoumis
entre le Hamas et et un groupe
terroriste qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé
est-ce que le mot indignité vous le
reprendriez tout à fait je crois
que en vu des des images horreurs que
nous avons vu C scène
macabre il y a pas de relativisme il y a
pas de de de contextualité il faut dire
les choses telles qu'elles sont et tout
ce qui essaent de relativiser des et de
trouver des des un raisonnement je crois
qui c'est contre les valeurs
républicaines la première ministre qui a
dit nous soutenons Israël personne ne
peut remettre en cause le droit d'Israël
à se défendre que dire de la réponse de
la France depuis le début de cette crise
samedi qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé de
de tous les messages officiels et aussi
des concitoyens français pour l'heure je
suis tout à fait réconforté et le peuple
d'Israël est réconforté de l'expression
de solidarité de soutien de la part de
de la France de la classe politique de
de et tout le peuple les élus et c'est
c'est très important pour le peuple
d'Israël juste justement à ce moment-ci
et c'est c'est fort c'est un message
fort et apprécié que peut faire la
France est-ce que vous vous souhaiteriez
un message particulier de la part de la
France une action particulière sur le
plan diplomatique je pense que la France
est déjà fait pas mal de au niveau
diplomatique comme la première ministre
d'rieur en a détaillé des contacts avec
tous les gouvernements de la région et
c'est très important pour éviter un
embrasement de la guerre dans la région
et euh je je je je je félicite le
gouvernement français pour pour cette
intervention un mot sur ce qui se passe
aussi à Gaza puisque on est à la veille
à priori dans un siège complet de
l'enclave de Gaza il y a déjà plus de
1000 personnes qui sont mortes depuis
samedi dans les bombardements faut-il
des corridur humanitaire notamment pour
évacuer des femmes ou des enfants qui
seraient pris comme cela dans bien les
les les bombardements de Gaza
premièrement je conseillerai de regarder
les les chiffres qui sont publiés en
fait par par par le Hamas sur les sur
les sur les blessés sur les morts avec
caution parce que c'est sont pas des
chiffres vérifiables d'acord de notre
part l'armée et le gouvernement
israélien fait tout pour éviter des
victimes civiles et tous les objets les
objectifs des des bombardements ou des
tirs sont des des des objectifs
militaires et eu et le le blocus dont
vous parlez c'est pour éviter de de
l'essence qui arrive qui soit fourni
pour pour les les les apparats du Hamas
et la même chose l'électricité
malheureusement je sais que ça touche
également la population mais mais c'est
pour éviter que que la l'industrie de
l'armement continue d'accord et il nous
reste 30 secondes que dire de la
situation sur le territoire français
est-ce que vous avez eu des remontées
d'incidents antisémites sur le
territoire une recrudescence en
particulier le ministre de l'Intérieur
parle d'une cinquantaine de faits est-ce
que vous craignez cette recrue d'esence
je pense qu'il faut être très vigilant
et sur le terrain et également sur sur
les réseaux
sociaux parce que les extrémistes dans
dans ces cas-là il ils ont tendance à
passer de du verbal à à l'action et
comme nous on a vu dans dans le passé
donc cette récurissence de d'acte
d'antisémitisme peut est dangereuse il
faut être vigilant et bien merci merci
d'être venu au micro de Public Sénat
pour réagir après cette séance
particulièrement solennelle qu'on a
suivi sur l'ne de Public Sénat merci
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur merci bien voilà
pour cette réaction de l'ambassadeur
d'Israël en France France autre réaction
salle des conférences celle du président
du groupe LR au Sénat il s'agit de Bruno
rotaillo à votre micro Quentin oui
bonjour Bruno rillo chef de fil des
sénateurs err ici au Sénat un mot sur ce
que peut faire le Parlement ce que peut
faire le Sénat dans cette crise vous
nous l'anonz vous allez prendre une une
initiative parlementaire bien sûr je
pense que poser des questions
d'actualité c'est important pour que le
le gouvernement reste mobilisé et pour
dire notre solidarité absolue et totale
vis-à-vis d'Israël et du peuple
israélien mais on peut aller plus loin
il nous Pr parant avec plusieurs groupes
une résolution pour condamner les choses
et surtout les nommer et c'est je pense
que c'est le plus important aujourd'hui
effectivement on a vu le président du
Sénat Jard l'archer parler de crime
contre l'humanité par rapport à ses
exactions ces crimes terribles qu'on a
vu dans les kibuts autour de la bande de
Gaza pourquoi est-ce que c'est si
important notamment que l'exécutif et
les partenaires européens utilisent ces
mots comme c'est ce qu'a demandé la
droite sénatoriale c'est fondamental et
vous savez Gérard arché utilise toujours
les bons mots en tout cas il réfléchit
quand il s'exprme
ça n'est pas un crime de guerre crime de
guerre ça voudrait dire que on considère
le Hamas comme une armée régulière c'est
un groupe terroriste ça n'est donc pas
de cette catégorie dont il s'agit il
s'agit bien d'un crime contre l'humanité
qui correspond d'ailleurs à une
catégorie juridique et qui correspond
surtout à ce qui s'est passé dans
l'horreur c'est absolument indiciible
puisque des enfants des vieillards des
femmes qui ont été massacré brûlés vif
torturés et et désormais pris en otage
non non je pense que la qualification de
crime contre l'humanité il faut pas en
avoir peur il faut l'assumer on voit que
Matignon va réunir l'Élysée pardon va
réunir les chefs de partis demain a
priori au déjeuner si si nos
informations sont correctes qu'est-ce
qu'on peut attendre politiquement de la
séquence une forme de front républicain
de front commun dans cette crise en
Israël en tout cas bien sûr qu'il faut
il faut faire front il faut que le
peuple israélien sente que la France est
vraiment tout prêt à leur côté mais il
faut aussi faire plus il faut bien
vérifier dans les fonds et DESS si la
France euh distribue des fonds notamment
pour le peuple palestinien mais souvent
il y a la corruption et il faudrait
s'assurer que ces fonds ne vont pas dans
la poche des terroristes donc ce que
j'attends aussi de la France c'est pas
seulement des actes politiques de
communication ce que j'attends c'est une
vraie action wo il nous reste 30
secondes pour évoquer ces craintes de
voir une importation du conflit qui se
qui touche le Proche Orient en France on
a vu Gérald Darmanin et Gabriel hatal ce
matin se montré très ferme il parle
d'une cinquantaine de fait antisémite
depuis samedi et qu'est-ce que vous avez
comme retour vous dans les départements
est-ce que il y a cette crainte qui est
forte aujourd'hui la crainte elle existe
s'est exprimé par la voix du ministre de
l'Intérieur ce weekend puisque dès ce
weekend aussitôt il a réagi pour
indiquer que les les lieux notamment les
synagogues et cetera bénéficieraiit
d'une protection voilà des
éc gendob exactement c'est c'est très
important ce qui veut bien dire qu'il y
a un problème quand même ce qui veut
bien dire que on est face à un FA phomè
où il y a une identification non pas au
drapeau français de gens qui sont pour
autant français mais à d'autres drapeaux
et parfois même à ces actes terroristes
et souvenez-vous d'ailleurs dans la
minute de silence que après les
attentats en 2015 certains professeur
avaient demandé dans certaines écoles
cette minute n'avait pas pu être
observée bien merci merci Bruno rillot
président du groupe LR au Sénat pour
cette réaction en direct au micro public
sén merci merci merci beaucoup Quentin
et place au débrief de question au
gouvernement avec sur ce plateau la
sénatrice Union centriste de l'Orne
Nathalie Goulet bonjour également sur ce
plateau le sénateur communiste de Paris
Yanne brossa bonjour nouvellement élu
bonjour et bienvenue on entend Bruno
rotaillot qui parle d'une proposition de
résolution qu'il compte soumettre aussi
à différents groupes Nathalie Goulet
votre réaction et souhaitez-vous vous
joindre à et bien cette proposition de
résolution du président du groupe LR
écoutez je je suis pas Saint- Thomas je
crois que que ce que je vois et pour
l'instant la résolution je l'ai pas vu
mais il y a pas de raisol il y a pas de
raison qu'on s'y associe pas si elle
correspond à ce que nous pensons sur le
sujet pas de pas de raison de de vous y
opposer est-ce que c'est la même chose
du côté du groupe communiste Yann brossa
bon vous dites difficile de parler de
quelque chose don qu'on n pas encore vu
mais en l'occurrence cette proposition
de résolution ne nous a pas été soumise
donc il est par conséquent un peu
compliqué pour moi de de me prononcer
dessus en revanche Cécile cuquerman
notre présidente de groupe présidente du
groupe CRCE au Sénat a demandé qu'un
débat puisse être organisé sur ce qui
s'est passé et sur la situation au
proche- Orient parce que tirer un parce
que je pense qu'il est effectivement
utile que nous puissions échanger sur
cette situation et sur le rôle que la
diplomatie française doit jouer pour
qu'on retrouve dans cette région du
monde un chemin de paix vous inquiétez
de la tournure que prend aujourd'hui le
débat aussi en France cela faisait
partie également de de ce que vous
disiez à l'intérieur du communiqué du
groupe communiste je trouve parfaitement
légitime qu'on ait l'expression d'une
émotion et d'une solidarité vis-à-vis
des victimes de ces actes terroristes
c'est parfaitement naturel et le Sénat
est tout à fait dans son rôle lorsqu'il
le fait et c'est ce qui a été fait cet
après-midi simplement je pense qu'il y a
une deuxième question qui doit se poser
maintenant c'est comment on retrouve un
chemin de paix comment la France permet
que dans cette région du monde on puisse
envisager une solution de paix parce que
le risque c'est un embrasement de
l'ensemble du Proche Orient et donc
c'est la question que nous que nous
souhaitons évoquer Nathalie Goulet
est-ce que c'est déjà le moment de
pouvoir parler de processus de paix
quand on voit effectivement
l'embrasement qui est en train de gagner
et bien l'ensemble du Moyen-Orient et et
notamment et bien le blocus de Gaza fait
par Israël aujourd'hui en réponse à cet
attentat moi jeis un tout petit peu plus
pragmatique on a eu une question une
séance de question d'actualité on a eu
assez peu de réponses n'est-ce pas bon
je pense notamment à la question d'Hervé
Marseille sur le financement du
terrorisme vous savez que c'est un de
mes dadas euh nous avons l le rôle de du
Qatar le rôleiranatar le rôle de l'Iran
les financements européens qui ne sont
pas contrôlés les financements
d'association qui ne sont pas contrôlés
et chaque année au moment du projet de
loi de finances je dépose des
amendements avec mon groupe pour plus de
contrôle chaque année on nous explique
que tout va bien j'espère qu'aujourd'hui
de façon extrêmement pragmatique et
parce que ces attaques terroristes ont
été organisés financés ces gens ont été
entraînés c'est pas arrivé comme ça par
hasard dans un clin d'œil vous voyez que
tout ça a fait l'objet d'une d'une
terrible organisation et aussi d'un
financement mortifère vous appelez à la
suspension de ces aides on a vu qu'il y
avait tout un débat européen avec des
désaccords aujourd'hui attendez non non
mais attendez si on supprime les aides
européennes aujourd'hui à Gaza on fait
le jeu du Hamas les gens qui veulent
supprimer les aides n'ont rien compris
au problème je parle pas de ça je parle
du contrôle des aides je parle pas de
leur suppression pas de suspension mais
du contrôle bien sûr et on a aussi et on
a aussi une TR on a aussi un problème
avec avec le Qatar avec l'Iran avec des
associations tout à fait nationales
européennes qui ont financé des
mouvements terroristes qui se retrouvent
là-bas donc là c'est pas une résolution
qu'il faut c'est appliquer des
dispositifs ou en prendre de nouveau
allez on continue les réactions salle
des conférences on a entendu les
présidents de groupe on va écouter
Patrick canner le président du groupe
socialiste au micro de Quentin ou
bonjour Patrick canner merci de nous
rejoindre ici en direct sur laine de
public s on voit cette proposition d'une
résolution voulue par Bruno rotaillo
est-ce que les socialistes pourraient
joindre leur signature à cette
résolution BR rotillot en sa qualité de
président du premier groupe a pris déjà
ce type d'initiative sur l'Ukraine sur
aussi le donc
leabprès de l'Arménie voilà donc on n
est pas du tout opposé il faut bien sûr
voir son conten mais ce qui est très
important c'est de montrer que sur des
sujets qui peuvent être très consensuels
en droit international et bien oui les
socialistes sont prêts à signer en
fonction bien sûr de son contenu est-ce
que dans cette résolution il pourrait
être question de de ces fameux crimes
contre l'humanité que Gérard lincher
souhaite qualifier comme tel il appelle
l'exécutif à à utiliser ces mots il
appelle l'exécutif à dire à nos
partenaires européens de reprendre cette
expression vous êtes d'accord avec ça
oui il faut nommer les choses vous savez
la notion de crime contre l'humanité
relève du droit international c'est
extrêmement précis ce que nous avons
vécu assister depuis le 7 octobre montre
que voilà ce n'est pas une une armée
régulière qui a commis ces ces actes
monstrueux insoutenable c'est bien une
bande de terroristes qui voulait
permettez-moi l'expression tu es du Juif
c'était bien cela dont il était question
malheureusement pendant ce ce weekend
face à à ce constat sans appel que vous
évoquez que dire de ce malaise à gauche
autour du fait de nommer le Hamas comme
un un un groupe terroriste vous avez
parlé d'indignité lors de cette séance
vous visez très clairement les les
insoumis ils ont commis une indignité en
refusant C cette je je n' visise pas les
insoumis en tant que parti je vise
certains leaders et pas tous d'ailleurs
monsieur Ruffin a une position
différente courageuse et un autre député
nous le savons de Paris je considère que
effectivement à force de tourner autour
du pot peut-être pour des raisons
électorale mais ça c'est fi de de
l'évoquer et bien ils sont en train de
se couper de ce que devrait être la
gauche de responsabilité vous connaissez
mes critiques sur laanupè sur LFI et
bien j'ai le sentiment malheureusement
que j'avais raison et depuis de nombreux
mois donc que lesfi fassent son
introspection pour faire bouger les
lignes justement on voit le chef de
votre partie le premier secrétaire
Olivier fort qui hésite à quitter
officiellement laanupe on a vu dans le
monde que ça aurait pu être dés hier que
ça a été annoncé on voit que ça il y a
une hésitation faut-il que votre chef de
fil le dise clairement le PS
n'appartient plus à la nuupe jusqu'à
nouvel ordre vous savez Olivier fort est
à la tête d'un parti démocratique qui
prend ses décisions de manière
collective et démoc bu national il
aurait pu le proposer d il y a un bureau
national hier mais nous avons un conseil
national ce samedi donc c'estàd le
Parlement du PS et une résolution en ce
sens sera portée discutée nous verrons
bien si elle obtient la majorité et donc
vous vous soutiendrez samedi le fait de
sortir de l'ANUP moi je considère que il
y aura eu un avant et un après 7 octobre
au sein de la gauche française mais
malheureusement nos affaires
politiciennes sont tellement peu de
choses par rapport au malheur que vit
Israël aujourd'hui s bien sûr merci
Patrick canner pour cette réaction micro
public merci merci beaucoup Quentin nos
affaires politiciennes n'ont pas
grand-chose à faire dans cette situation
mais on voit la Nupe qui est en train de
se désagréger Yan brossa aujourd'hui
face à la position de la France
insoumise qui pour l'instant ne refuse
de parler du Hamas comme d'une
organisation terroriste et d'attaque
terroriste après ce qui s'est passé
samedi en tout cas en ce qui nous
concerne nous je parle de de de notre
groupe de de de ma sensibilité politique
Fabien Roussel a exprimé des choses
extrêmement claires nous avons des
dénoncer ces actes qui sont des actes
terroristes et et qui nécessitent je
crois une condamnation unanime après les
autres formations politiques de l'ANUP
peuvent avoir des propos différents mais
pour ce qui nous concerne ce que nous
avons dit et je crois extrêmement clair
et ne souffre d'aucune espèce d'ambiguïé
je trouve est-ce que vous avez besoin de
rompre avec Alfi en ce moment ou est-ce
que vous dites c'est pas le moment mais
honnêtement on a une situation au Proche
Orient qui est absolument dramatique et
on va commencer à compter les points à
intérieur de de notre coalition tout ça
ne me paraît pas très digne et je pense
que dans les moments dramatiques comme
ceux que nous vivons en ce moment on a
besoin de dignité et je trouve
d'ailleurs que notre séance de de
question au gouvernement au Sénat a
témoigné d'une forme de dignité et si
nous pouvions continuer sur cette lignée
là je pense que nous en sortirions
grandi alors vous parlez de cette séance
de question au gouvernement parmi les
TSF on retient aussi l'intervention de
Roger carucci qui est président du
groupe d'amitié France Israël et on
écoute ce qu'il a dit tout à l'heure en
séance nous sommes là pour vous dire
qu'il faut utiliser les mots crime
contre l'humanité c'est la réalité ce
mot cette expression utilisezla
faites-la utiliser par l'Europe
franchement vu ce qui s'est passé crime
contre l'humanité c'est bien le minimum
la légitime défense de l'État d'Israël
c'est un droit permanent quand vous
recevez des milliers de de missiles et
que vous assistez à ce qui s'est passé
dans les kibut légitime défense c'est le
minimum et faites en sorte madame la
Première ministre que celles et ceux qui
dans la République trahissent les
valeurs de la République trahissent les
valeurs de la nation en ne soutenant pas
l'état d'Israël et en faisant l'apologie
du terrorisme faites en sorte qu'il soit
sévèrement puni plusieurs choses dans
cette intervention mais tout d'abord sur
ce terme de crime contre l'humanité on a
aussi entendu l'ambassadeur d'Israël
reprendre ce terme le président du Sénat
parler de crime contre l'humanité est-ce
que vous adhéz à cette expression
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est ce qui
qualifie ce qui s'est passé samedi pour
vous Nathalie Goulet a priori après les
images et est-ce qu'on a déjà entendu et
les témoignages ça ça s'y apparente
puisque c'est le plus grand massacre de
juifs depuis la Choa donc il y a bien là
une volonté d'élimination physique d'une
population civile je pense qu'on y est
très très après moi je voudrais d'abord
revenir sur ce qu'a dit notre collègue y
brossa c'est la dignité de cette séance
la dignité des hommages la dignité de
chacun d'entre nous dans nos à nos à nos
places et sur nos bancs et sur les
différents bans du Sénat je pense que
c'était l'honneur du Sénat cette
question et et cette séance aujourd'hui
on a entendu aussi l'intervention de
Roger carucci qui parle aussi de de son
inquiétude sur et bien des céit une
allusion à la France insoumise et sans
doute au NPA he sur le manque de de
soutien au peuple israélien plus
largement l'inquiétude que l'on sent
monter c'est sur la recrudescence de
l'antisémitisme des acte antisémite qui
pourrait monter après ces attentats
est-ce que c'est ce que vous craigz
aussi aujourd'hui Yan brossa en tout cas
je ne souhaite pas qu'on mélange tout il
y a une nécessité absolue de lutter
vigoureusement contre l'antisémitisme et
de faire preuve d'une vigilance absolue
et ceux qui prononcent des propos
antisémites ceux qui se livrent à des
actes antisémites doivent être condamnés
et sévèrement condamnés c'est très clair
ensuite vous avez le débat politique et
vous avez des formations politiques pas
la mienne mais en l'occurrence des
formations politiques qui expriment des
opinions sur un certain nombre de sujets
elles ont le droit de le faire et j'ai
le droit de dire que je ne suis pas
d'accord avec elles mais ne
mélons Méons
aujourd'hui je ne suis pas favorable à
ce qu'on dissolve la France insoumise et
je pense que les gens qui avancent de
telles propositions ne croient pas
eux-mêmes en ce qu'ils
disentè ou alors ils sont tombés sur la
tête personne envisage sérieusement de
dissoudre la France insoumise tout ça me
paraît totalement absurde je peux avoir
des désaccords avec avec cette formation
politique je ne suis pas favorable à ce
qu'elle soit dissoute allez on continue
les réactions salle des conféren et on
peut d'ailleurs poser cette question à
Claude maluret le président du groupe
les indépendants au Sénat au micro de
Quentin oui voilà Claude maluré vous
vouliez pas forcément parler des
insoumis mais puisque Tam me demande de
vous poser la question j'en suis voilà
j'y suis contraint mais voilà on entend
ces ces sénateurs notamment LR qui
demande de dissoudre la France insoumise
alors c'est certes très difficile à
faire et c'est même pas faisable
techniquement mais qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de ce de ce message politique DLR
je pense que c'est pas la peine de
dissoudre les insoumis ils sont en train
de se dissoudre tout seul chaque chaque
épisode politique depuis plusieurs mois
il ne cesse de tomber plus bas il ne
cesse de s'éloigner de plus en plus de
ce que pense le peuple français ils se
réclament du peuple français et ils sont
en décalage de plus en plus fort avec
avec ce peuple peuple euh je crois qu'il
y a même pas de commentaire à faire ils
sont en train de s'autodissoudre un mot
sur la séance qu'on a vécu aujourd'hui
une séance solennelle ainsi président de
groupe dont vous qui avez posé des
questions sur le drame qui touche Israël
c'était l'idée de montrer que le Sénat a
était unanime dans son soutien au peuple
israélien alors ça n'était pas l'idée
parce qu'on ne s'est pas concerté mais
c'est la réalité la réalité à la
différence de l'Assemblée nationale où
une petite minorité n'est pas d'accord
avec avec les autres ici au Sénat
évidemment euh on a le sens et tout le
monde a le sens des réalités le sens
surtout des drames le sens de l'horreur
de ce qui s'est passé et par conséquent
il viendrait l'idée de personne ici de
ne pas évoquer l'émotion la colère le
dégoût de ce qui s'est passé en Israël
Bruno rotaillot était à ce micro il y a
quelques minutes il annonce qu'une
résolution va être portée par son groupe
politique est-ce que vous pourriez
signer cette résolution vous avez été
approché à ce propos oui bien sûr on en
a discuté avec Bruno retill alors
qu'est-ce qu'elle va contenir vous le
savez j'ai pas encore vu la résolution
il m'a appelé pour me dire qu'il allait
la déposer et qu'il me l'envirait il
doit l'envoyer cet après-midi peut-être
elle est déjà à mon bureau mais bien
entendu il faut que tout le monde soit
d'accord sur les termes mais a priori
nous sommes parfaitement d'accord pour
signer une résolution de ce type et j'ai
une guère question si vous voulez bien
on a vu Gabriel Attal et également
géralde dararmanin en visite ce matin en
banlieu parisienne pour et bien évoquer
ces actes antisémites il y en aurait une
cinquantaine depuis dit est-ce qu'on
peut craindre une recrudescence de ces
actes antisémites avec une forme
d'importation du conflit du Proche
Orient en France est-ce est-ce qu'on se
fait peur pour rien euh étant donné ce
qui s'est passé étant donné la gravité
de ce qui s'est passé étant donné la la
sensibilité
euh dans tous les pays du monde mais
particulièrement en France euh aux
problèmes du proche- Orient au conflit
israël-palestinien bien entendu qu'on
peut le le craindre bien entendu qu'on
peut le le redouter et c'est le travail
du ministre de l'intérieur et du
ministre de l'éducation nationale de
faire en sorte que ça ne se passe pas de
prévenir plutôt que guérir donc ils sont
en responsabilité et il faut les
soutenir c'est ça ils ont rappelé que
500 lieux des écoles des synagogues des
endroits où les Français de de
confession juives ont l'habitude d'aller
serait protéger par 10000 policiers et
gendarmes c'est une citation de ce matin
de géralde de Darmanin merci pour cette
réaction à notre micro Claude malur
merci à vous merci merci beaucoup
Quentin pour cette nouvelle réaction
naalie Goul pouvez pas terminer ce débat
sans parler non plus de la situation des
Palestiniens aujourd'hui et notamment
avec le blocus de Gaza qui est la
réponse l'une des réponses d'Israël
après l'attaque de samedi ou aussi la
population palestinienne qui est pris en
otage par le Hamas euh il faut quand
même pas l'oublier l'absence complète de
gouvernance etette démocratie au sein de
l'Autorité palestinienne où il y a pas
eu d'élection depuis je sais pas combien
de temps et puis tout un tas de
problèmes internes pour lesquels la
population palestinienne souffre aussi
une sensation de de double standard
comme si les morts d'un côté pesaient
plus lourd que les morts de l'autre côté
tout ça est une situation qui dure
depuis longtemps on peut pas non plus
complètement passer l'éponge aujourd'hui
sur ce sujet qu'il faut quand même
traiter qu'il faudra traiter je sais pas
ce que dira la résolution mais en tous
les cas il est parfaitement évident
qu'il faut
débarrasser le territoire de Gaza de du
Hamas qui est une une organisation
terroriste qui qui tient les autres
palestiniens en otage donc c'est aussi
un sujet et comment le faire comment le
faire aujourd'huiut travaille il faut
qu'on y travaille de façon beaucoup plus
simple moi moi j'ai une j'ai une
solution qui est tout qui est tout à
fait dans la ligne du travail que je
fais eu qui est déjà de couper les
financement et de couper les aides
étrangères l'Iran et le Qatar et ça
c'est un problème qui peut être aussi
franco-français euh votre réaction
effectivement à cette situation vous
appelez d'ailleurs euh le groupe appelle
à la nécessité d'un d'un processus
politique un processus de paix qui n'a
jamais paru plus éloigné aujourd'hui
après l'attaque de samedi après la
réaction des arméis d'Israël bien sûr
mais c'est pourtant je crois le sujet
qui devra être à l'ordre du jour dans
les jours qui viennent si on ne veut pas
un embrasement général et ce processus
de paix il supposera que demain puisse
naître un État palestinien souverain
parce qu'on a aujourd'hui un peuple qui
est un peuple sans état bien sûr le
contexte politique général ne justifie
rien mais il explique beaucoup de la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes et
il faudra demain que le peuple
palestinien puisse disposer d'un état au
côté bien sûr de l'État d'Israël qui
doit ir sa sécurité assurée mais ce sont
quand même ces questions là qui sont
devant nous et qu'il va bien falloir
poser et il faudrait que la diplomatie
française puisse peser en ce sens c'est
dans ce sens que Fabien Roussel va
s'exprimer il doit être reçu avec les
autres chefs de parti demain à l'Élysée
par Emmanuel Macron oui bien sûr Fabien
Roussel s'est déjà exprimé en ce sens
depuis plusieurs jours maintenant et il
continuera de le faire à chaque fois
qu'il sera interrogé sur le sujet un
dernier mot sur et bien peut-être la N
cité aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit d'avoir
une parole
peut-être responsable dans politique
responsable en France sur ce sujet alors
qu'on assiste à une forme de
d'impossible union nationale que l'on
voit quand même aujourd'hui dans
l'hémicycle aujourd'hui vous avez vu
l'Union nationale dans l'émicycleicycle
du Sénat mais pas dans celui de
l'Assemblée oui non mais d'accord mais
mais l'union nationale c'est autre chose
c'est aussi avoir un objectif l'objectif
c'est la paix et vous l'avez dit très
bien elle a jamais été aussi éloignée
sans compter le le Liban qui s'embrasse
donc vous avez quand même un cartel
mortifère le Hamas le Hezbollah les
Frères musulmans l'Iran le Qatar je veux
dire on a assez à débattre quand on aura
régler ce problème je pense que la paix
aura déjà bien avancé bien merci merci
beaucoup à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à ce débrief des questions au
Gouvernement qu'on ne va pas terminer
sans aller voir une dernière fois
Mathias Arz dans l'hémicycle du cén
Mathias pour nous raconter un petit peu
ce qui s'est passé lors de cette séance
où on a vu de très nombreux présidents
de groupe prendre la parole oui
absolument Tam c'est une séance qui tout
d'abord s'est ouverte avec cette
information donné par la première
ministre Elizabeth borne 10 français
tués dans ces attaques du Hamas et 18
toujours portés disparu parmi lesquels
pourrai se trouver des enfants une
séance marquée vous l'avez dit par des
prises de parole de présidents de groupe
6 au total c'est à noter ont interrogé
la première ministre sur cette situation
en Israël certains insistant sur la
gravité de ces attaques comme le
président socialiste Patrick canner qui
a qualifier le Hamas de filiale de la
mort ou encore la présidente du groupe
RDSE maris carer qui a souhaité rendre
hommage aux victimes d'autres présidents
comme le président Claude maluret des
indépendants ont alerté sur le risque de
voir des dictatures du monde entier
ressurgir et s'unir et la nécessité
forcément de s de s'y préparer tout
comme l'a évoqué le président de l'Union
centriste Hervé marseill qui n'a pas
hésité à pointer du doigt une certaine
complaisance de la part de la France
envers le Qatar ou encore l'Iran qui
seraiit donc des soutiens du Hamas enfin
l'écologiste Guillaume gontar et le
président du groupe groupe Renaissance
François patria ont eu interroger la
président la première ministre sur la
recherche de la paix et la sortie de
crise que vous étiez en en train
d'évoquer en plateau ce à quoi a répondu
ellisabeth borne que la résolution du
conflit israello par palestinien par la
voie politique avait toujours été et
continuera d'être la position de la
France Merci Merci beaucoup Mathias pour
toutes ces explications pour ce
décryptage de cette première séance de
questions au gouvernement de la session
qui vous l'avez vu a été très largement
marquée par des questions autour de la
situation d'Israël place tout de suite
et bien à une audition l'audition du
ministre de l'éducation nationale
Gabriel hatal qui d'ailleurs se rendait
ce matin dans une école juive avec et
bien le ministre de l'Intérieur Géral
dararmanin il s'exprime cet après-midi
devant les sénateurs de la commission de
la culture c'est une prise de contact
avec la commission de la culture et il
devrait y avoir des questions sur de
très nombreux sujets
regardez comme vous le savez déjà
monsieur le ministre vous trouverez au
sein de notre commission des
interlocuteurs attentif exigeant mais
constructif soucieux à l'image de notre
rapporteur Jacques groperrin
d'entretenir le dialogue avec vous et
vos services sur des sujets essentiels
pour les élèves et l'ensemble de la
communauté éducative je tiens je pense
en particulier à la question de
l'attractivité du métier d'enseignement
ignant pardon sur lequel nous avons
beaucoup travaillé depuis de nombreuses
années ici à la lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire et au cyber
harcèlement sur laquelle le Sénat s'est
penché en 2021 ou encore à la politique
d'inclusion scolaire par ailleurs comme
vous le savez sans doute nous avons
créer avec la commission des lois une
mission de contrôle disposant de pouvoir
d'enquête consacré aux modalités de
signalement et de traitement par les
pouvoirs publics des pressions menaces
et agressions subies par les enseignants
dont les travaux de cette commission de
cette mission vont vont reprendre et
dans le cadre de laquelle nous aurons
également plaisir évidemment à à vous
entendre mais notre audition du jour
est est
consacrée aux priorités que vous avez
défin dans le cadre de vos prises de
fonctions nous aurons aussi l'occasion
de vous entendre dans dans quelques
jours sur le projet de doix de finance
donc par conséquent mes chers collègues
je vous demanderai cet après-midi de de
ne pas aborder les questions liées au
projet de dois de finance puisque nous
auront une une
audition d'ici quelques semaines
pouvez-vous ainsi Monsieur le Ministre
nous présenter votre feuille de route à
la tête du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale un mois et demi après la
rentrée pouvez-vous nous dresser un
premier bilan de celle-ci et des
premières mesures fortte je pense
évidemment à l'interdiction du port de
de laba ou du report des épreuves de
spécialité du bac au MO join que vous
avez été amené à prendre pourriez-vous
nous faire aussi un point sur la mise en
place du pacte enseignant êtes-vous
satisfait des des premières adhésions
des des enseignants euh monsieur le
ministre je vais vous laisser la parole
pour une intervention liminire d'une
quinzaine de minutes après vous avoir
rappelé que cette audition est captée et
diffusée en différé sur le site internet
du Sénat et puis ensuite comme il en est
de coutume je
donnerai la parole d'abord au rapporteur
que nous venons de désigner Jacques
groserin et ensuite bien sûr à à chacun
des des sén chacune des sénatrices et
chacun des sénateurs qui souhaitera le
faire monsieur le ministre la parole est
à
vous merci monsieur le Président cher
Laurent Laffond mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs vous l'avez dit
c'est ma première audition devant cette
commission mais en réalité c'est ma
première audition parlementaire depuis
mes nouvelle fonction de ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
vous n'êtes donc pas en retard par
rapport au calendrier je suis très
heureux de vous retrouver beaucoup
d'entre vous avec lesquels j'ai eu le
plaisir de travailler dans mes
précédentes fonctions au budget
retrouver Jacques groserin nous avions
tous les deux été rapporteurs quand
j'étais député de la loi sur
l'orientation et la réussite des
étudiants début du précédent quinquena
et on avait eu une CMP conclusive ce qui
montre la capacité qu'on peut avoir à
travailler tous ensemble je vous
remercie vraiment de votre invitation à
m'exprimer devant vous dès la reprise de
vos travaux je profite également de
cette opportunité pour saluer et
féliciter celles et ceux d'entre vous
pour qui c'est aussi une première
audition dans cette assemblée ou au sein
de cette commission l'éducation
nationale est une préoccupation majeure
des Français à juste titre tant l'école
occupe une place singulière dans notre
société et dans l'histoire de notre
nation vous êtes le relais de cette
préoccupation à travers les travaux que
vous menez tant au sein de cette
commission que dans l'hémicycle c'est
donc pleinement conscient du rôle qui
est le vote notamment en matière de
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement et
avec la plus grande rigueur que je
tâcherai à répondre à vos interrogations
aujourd'hui mais évidemment dans les
mois qui viennent l'école je le disais
c'est ce qui réunit les familles et la
République au sein d'une même espérance
commune que chaque enfant de France
puisse par l'école et grâce à l'école
s'élever et s'émanciper qu'aucun destin
ne soit écrit d'avance c'est la promesse
de la République et cette promesse c'est
celle de son école lors de cette rentrée
scolaire j'ai eu l'occasion de préciser
mon ambition pour ce ministère pour ces
quelques 12 millions d'élèves pour leur
famille et pour plus d'un200000
personnels dont 860000 enseignants c'est
chaque année je le dis un petit miracle
d'organisation que cette rentrée
scolaire et je veux ici remercier de
nouveau très chaleureusement tous les
enseignants les directeurs d'écoes les
chefs d'établissements tous les
personnels des rectorats qui ont œuvré
pour cette rentrée je souhaite vous
faire part en introduction des échanges
on m'a indiqué qu'il fallait pas être
trop long pour qu'on puisse échanger les
chantier que j'ai engagé dès ma prise de
fonction et d'abord en vous disant que
je suis lucide malgré le travail conduit
C